e
MonDay addition of the science
technology and energy committee Monday
March 25th
we're going to get started even though
some members are not here yet because we
have um quite a few people who would
like to testify on the first bill we're
hearing this morning and before we start
that we'll start our meeting as is
customary by joining Henry noell as he
pledge aliance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for stands one nation under God
all so we have two public hearings here
this morning and then this afternoon we
have a full committee work session on
three bills that we heard last week this
morning's bills are s SP 451 relative to
an expedited track for certain
applications to the site evaluation
committee and sp540 re requiring the
department of energy to investigate
behind the meter and utility scale
energy storage so we'll start with SB
451 and welcome our good friend from the
Senate Senator David Waters to introduce
this legislation good morning Senator
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee Senator David Waters District
4 to introduce Senate Bill
451 relative to an expedited track of
certain applications to the site
evaluation committee and I I feel like
this bill is the third part of our
Trifecta with uh House Bill 281 last
year and this year House Bill 609 and
now um Senate Bill 4551 and I think the
content of this bill looking as xited
track for existing facilities would be
quite familiar with you because I know
there was consideration and work put in
on uh this um as potentially being a
part of 609 but we thought it' be best
to have this come forward um as its own
bill which is what you have before you
and I think that uh we're going to uh
hear a lot of the the reasons why um
this legislation was was but brought
forward and why it's particularly timely
right right now in our uh effort to make
sure New Hampshire is is ready for all
the changes in the industry uh when it
comes to site uh evaluation and this
this process
um now uh a couple of things I will will
mention um it's anticipated that a lot
of the support for new and renewable
energy facilities will take place at
existing sites
um there's substantial funding through
the IRA act for these kinds of
transitions um some related to wind
energy a lot related to um hydrogen some
80 billion dollar would be available of
course small nuclear as as well so
there's a lot of um funding that is now
available from the federal government
and recognizing the fact this energy
transition is going to need us to be
able to look at um site
evaluation a lot of the work of the SEC
as we've been seeing over the last few
few years of our work on that process is
on land use and uh public transparency
and it is felt that this um possibility
have expedited uh process for those
sites that have already gone through
land use uh with public transparency to
make sure that as needed that that
continues in terms of transparency but
it might permit at existing facilities
some ex expeditious act action um there
um and then um thirdly
um having a faster uh sighting process
is really going to help us in terms of
the IRA and also the mounting
electrification demands that we're
seeing as we Electrify um the uh many
sectors of our economy including
Transportation Home Heating and uh
energy production as well um people who
have substantial funding besides the
federal government to to put into the um
creation of this new electrification
um are looking to states to have a good
process where they can come make their
Investments as you all know I'm
particularly interested in offshore wind
I see enormous potential there for
repurposing of some of our um sites now
to handle uh Power coming and from
offshore wind also the storage of that
energy and also the potential production
of hydrogen um just as a reminder bom
has now approved the Final maps for the
Gulf of Maine looks like the auctions
are going to be in the um summer early
early fall and then contracts have to be
done within 90 days after that so uh
people are going to be looking to New
Hampshire as well as to Maine and
Massachusetts to see what kind of
capacity we have for sighting facilities
that are related to that industry as as
well so what you have in the bill um
fundamentally um a new definition of
qualified expanding energy facility
you'll see that in the first page of the
bill and I'll revisit these in a moment
um and then you'll see the new timelines
a a a series of strike through and new
timelines uh bold numbers there in RSA
162 um H and uh places those guidelines
for the SEC to respond at certain points
of the of the process um public hearing
section is changed to make sure that
there is still adequate public hearing
uh time with these expedited um time
principles and then uh SEC will have to
update its administrative rules rules to
accommodate these sections in state they
law so if you turn to the bill you'll
see as I have mentioned the definition
of the
qualifying um site on on page one and I
think very crucial negotiations around
on lines eight and nine on page one no
large existing facility name plate
capacity um I do think we'll probably
want to have a little clarification to
make sure that that name capacity uh is
public so that the the public interest
in public hearing can know
about that and then existing facility
location or a budding um panel and then
the application for the certificate as
you'll see to make sure the certificate
is is uh is complete and then um on the
bottom of uh page two uh here are the
public notice um uh aspects as as well
uh and the one of our first changes from
60 days to 30 days um that that
um decision will be made that the
application is meets these re
requirements um I do think that we might
your committee might think about whether
or not we need some definition of public
interest as it is on line uh 29 you I
think you may hear about about some Curr
concerns about that and there there may
be a way to um provide some um
definitions to that as well on page
three you'll see the you know the series
of strikeouts 150 days to 90 days 365 to
180 days and this is not just to you
know do the old speed up of the uh
assembly line it's because because this
um kind of sighting application is
different because it's at an existing
site existing name plate that it seems
these are quite reasonable time limits
to set there um please do note on line
16 on page three public information
session in each County um and then uh
public hearing you'll see on page four
within 45 5 days of the acceptance of
the application to be held at least one
public hearing and then looking again
down in lines 24 Public hearings um then
in in terms of an adjudicative process
so a lot of effort here um to make sure
that the public interest um is
accommodated in in this uh uh this
process um I I just you know want to
want to pause and say that I know that
you're going to hear some um thoughts
that came up uh in in the Senate hearing
and I think you may have heard uh in
your other deliberations on on
sighting um the debate over whether this
should just be for certain kinds of
sources um I personally feel that we
have an opportunity here to transition
our energy Supply to cheaper and more
reliable um forms but I think we need to
provide flexibility to the industry as
well I I we do have turbines that are
now developed that can handle both
natural gas and hydrogen you can put up
to 20% of hydrogen now into a gas supply
I think the potential for hydrogen
production related to Offshore wind is
is really going to be a very significant
significant factor so I I think um I am
very supportive of of maintaining the
kind of flexibility we have here but
there are some there are certainly some
boys say no this should just be for what
we now would call clean energy
facilities I think we need the
flexibility that this bill um provides
there
um I've mentioned already uh you're
going to hear some things about the name
plate um having make sure there's some
transparency that and and also I just
you know in this in this expedited
process just to make sure that any given
site if it hasn't been through
environmental reviews earlier because
it's been there for quite some time we
make sure that um the SEC can actually
do its job and the de and fishing game
and all the other agencies that are
tasked under the revision of 609 to keep
keep doing the work the feds require
them to do and then let the revised SEC
with this formulation for existing
facilities get its work done as well so
thank you Mr chairman I I will stop
there and be glad to take any questions
I can answer but I got some you know
there's a backup team here uh who
certainly can speak in great detail
about this as well well thank you
Senator good introduction appreciate
that I do have one quick question are
you married to the word rep powering
because on line three the definition
qualified existing energy facility
expansion and repowering repowering
seems to mean
restarting
or resuming
operation whereas
repowering might be interpreted by some
people to mean something different yeah
so would you
be amenable to a change in language from
repowering to maybe resuming operation
or uh restarting operation something
like
that thank you for that question M
chairman and I do think that there would
be ways to um be have some clarity as to
what that means it's not just have the
switches been off turned the switch on
the idea here is a transition to other
sources of energy other other means of
energy production so whether that is you
know definitionally and legally
repurposing that's a good idea
representative somethingest
repurposing okay we'll talk about that
and if I may Mr chairman I think it
might be useful to make sure when you
look at the IRA Provisions to make sure
that whatever language we come up there
um is in accordance with the kind of um
repowering that will make these these
sites potentially available for all that
funding is repowering Def defined in the
ira that's that's what I'm okay take a
look yeah yeah okay representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question uh on the
same line that opening line where it
says qualified existing energy facility
expansion and then it goes on to say um
in the language of the bill that the
name plate capacity uh can be no larger
so is it is expansion the right word
there I'm sorry would you repeat yeah is
expansion the correct word if we're
going to be confined to the existing
name plate because that expansion
implies that you're perhaps going to be
expanding on the amount of energy coming
out of there and I know that's not my
only question on the bill but since
curious line three you know I I see just
see um well you know certainly a a given
there may be a name capacity which is
basically what the interconnection
capacity can take right and that to me
when that was suggested seemed to be key
because that that's the point isn't it
and it's not I mean yes how you produce
the power but how much power can you get
off a given site now I it may be that an
existing facility has never generated up
to the name the interconnection capacity
so I think it's quite reasonable to say
well if you've got the interconnection
capacity why not be able to use it so I
think that's why that word expansion is
is recognized as that kind of situation
okay that makes sense thank you
further questions for the senator
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh yeah so with lines
um 789 on page one y uh continuing on
that I I I guess I'm a little unclear
when it says uh expansion shall be no
larger than the existing facilities name
plate capacity is what we're really
talking about here is that the
additional energy produced is no more
than what's being produced now that
we're going to at most double what's
coming out of that site is that the
right way to interpret it thanks for
your question I think the right way to
interpret is how much existing name
plate capacity recognizes um the
interconnection as I understand it so
that really it's it's a matter of we're
we're going to just make sure that we're
within the interconnection capacity
right okay I think we'll have some more
technical am I basically okay on that
okay I think we'll have some some
further uh talk from the folks who you
know understand that what the name plate
is and I think that's just I may say I
think that that's a reason why it would
be good to have some transparency about
just what is that name capacity so
people know what we're what we're
talking about I mean so you can say
let's say that's a they can take a
thousand megawatts and come off the site
but the facility that's there now only
produces 800 well they go up this says
yeah you can you you know the new the
new facility that you build replace the
old one of a different fuel source you
can power you can power that up have
sufficient turbines to get the amount of
power you can get off the site follow up
followup thank you um and
then an issue I brought up when I
testified on this bill in front of the
Senate was uh this question about the ab
buding parcel and I suggested that there
be some sort of uh limitation on the
size of the abing parcel relative to the
original parcel you know imagining some
weird scenario where you have a
uh Power Plant on one acre and there's a
Thousand Acre or budding parcel I know
that's not going to happen but the point
is I it seems like you need some sort of
limitation on the size of the abing
parcel thanks for your question you know
my my sense is that why would we want to
prejudge that if you were to imagine a
kind of an energy Park that would have a
generation capacity run by some kind of
supply but let's say you also had 100
acres of solar that might be there or
let's say you wanted to have some pretty
substantial battery storage now those
might be on a budding parcels and be
part of this this mix and then you might
have a s a plant as well so I I I'd
rather have that I to me it seems to
make sense not to say well it can be 20
acres but not 25 acres that have it
dependent upon the project which of
course is going to get public hearing
representative liwicki has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you Senator
um I have a recollection that we had a
house bill that was going to actually
make it so that the SEC was no longer
effectively a phantom committee where
somebody would answer the phone and then
somebody would be at least administer it
and um I'm wondering how this uh bill um
relates to that you know is there is
somebody going to answer the phone is
somebody going to make meetings happen
and so forth because without that uh
basis at the SEC you can't do much uh
thanks for your question representative
so um I think there's been good
coordination here mean this committee
did Fabulous work on HB 609 with the
revision of SEC and this bill was
developed by becoming a revision to 162
H7 to kind of fit into what is being
being done in House Bill 609 which did
Fe receive a very favorable Hearing in
the in in a senate so I I I've said at
the start I think we really have you
know this Trifecta where we've moved
from 281 609 and now this bill kind of
to to come to to work together so I I
think we're I think we're good but I'm
sure there'll be some pretty good eyes
on this to make sure that we did do
things in accordance with
609 representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for coming in um this might be a simple
question I I don't know but it doesn't
seem to be a deadline for decision-
making by the committee on on the bill
is that is that incorporated in HB 609
or am I missing something shouldn't
there be a deadline for an expedited
process for decision-
making well that process under 609 has a
certain set of deadlines and now this
process because it's for existing
facilities is proposing the numbers that
you see
here for clarification on page three
lines 8 and n say within 180 days of the
acceptance of an application the
committee shall issue or deny a
certificate for an energy
facility representative Thomas Vice
chair Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh at the risk of that last
question that might have answered the
question I'm going to ask but I I'll
I'll ask it differently um I could do
the math running through the dates that
are changeed to make things faster but
overall overall how much faster does
this bill make that decision- making
process as opposed to the way it is now
I'm just curious is it three months six
months well you know or ask question
question
um this is going to be new so it's hard
to say and we haven't had you know
applications to the SEC for a little
while we've been in this you know
fortunate and this little kind of a
pause so we had chance to do this
legislation so it's hard to predict just
just what this will mean but I think
that when I mentioned you know plan
owners or potential investors or funding
under the IRA that anybody who now comes
in can look at this and will be able to
see we at least know that this step this
step and this step we can have responses
to so where the timeline ends I it
depends a lot of factors I mean let's
say at the start they say well your
application is not complete and so you
have to revise that or you know when it
does get into the SEC portion of the
adjudicative hearings that those will
will play out I do think that you know
we will see some stability of timeline
here and particularly in the early
phases um see that things that maybe
used to take a whole lot longer because
their existing facilities can be
expedited representative Ms has a
question thank you Mr chair and um thank
you senator for taking my questions and
my apologies for coming com in near the
end of your testimony if somebody
already asked this question feel free to
just say that they have and I'll get the
answer for my colleagues but on page
four um uh lines 3 through six um it the
bill deletes existing language and
statute that um if I read it right
allows the um the governing board of a
municipality where one of these
facilities is located to request the
separate public
meeting um why is that being taken
out um I may not give the absolutely
correct answer on this but I think that
this actually reflects what is being
done in
609 um and that um because we have
the I mean this I mean the SEC is a
state process and I think we decided um
I think Mr chairman thinking back to two
summers ago in that that study committee
that the feeling was that over a certain
size um it is the state's purview under
a certain size the town can is is more
involved um and it does not require that
state review and this recognized these
facilities are going to serve the whole
state not just one uh M
municipality that
said under existing Federal requirements
which we reflect in statute the dees
process the fishing game process the do
process all involved hearings in which
local people can you know the
municipality can be involved and then
you'll see in this bill a little bit
further down each
County the public
process the adjudicative public hearings
so I think that's why this is saying
this is the SEC is a state process for
for energy facility sighting and I think
that needs to be clear where those lines
it representative Corman has another
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again uh I have a couple of
questions about specific wording on page
two um one very minor thing on line
27 um where uh it says uh one or more
newspapers having a regular circulation
in the county in which the facility is
located um later on though apparently
there's the possibility of multiple
counties so we might want to say each
County something like that perhaps
perhaps um but my real question is on
lines 29 through
32 um and it's that uh actually the
bolded language and that the application
meets the requirements of uh RSA
whatever relative to a qualified
existing energy facility expansion and
repowering um not everything is going to
meet that but this statute is really for
um for allsite evaluation so I'm I'm a
little confused um it seems like there
should be something saying that you know
if the application meets it then certain
things happen I'm just a little confused
about this
well thanks for the question I'm not
sure whether I'll I mean this is
something maybe we can puzzle out I my
reading of this is
that um this is amending some existing
language so that it needs to have that
and that the application meets this
requirement and that's and within 30
days of filing so that that that to me
is what
kicks the the I mean I think that bold
phrase is what becomes dependent upon
the 60 going to the 30 right there um
and that we you know the public interest
is important and that that's something
that should be perhaps defined um but
also because this is creating this new
section under 162 that that reference to
it needs to be included because these
are the kinds of existing sites that
we're talking about I hope that's clear
enough but if not I think maybe you can
again yeah go ahead yeah maybe maybe
during our work session we can try to
clean it up and make clear you know what
applies to um the expedited review and
what what doesn't right again because
this this particular section of of the
law applies to all review not just
expedited um we just need to make clear
when when when when is it expedited when
not yeah if I if May um yes I think this
is something you could talk about some
more representative and thanks to the
follow-up question but do note that what
it
says I mean your question about what
that this applies to qualified well this
is referring back to that new section on
page one lines 3 to n right I mean
that's what it says it's the new um xi-
you know ROM 11- a so that that's that
that seems to me to be the delimiter and
the guard rail for this aspect of the
SEC expedited process so anyways I mean
think about it but I I think that's why
it's I think that's that is meant to be
the delimitation is back to that
definition I made a note to double check
that reference when we have our work
session so we'll do that further
questions for the
senator uh representative Corman thank
you again uh another question I had was
I noticed that the um the public hearing
uh is
within the public info session excuse me
is within 30 days of acceptance and then
the uh site evaluation Committee hearing
is within 45
days but I don't see anything that says
that the public info session should
preedee the public hearing and it seems
to
yeah make a note of that we'll we'll
look into that as
well representative McGee just was
thinking um is there any uh reason that
we should include in um language that
states that we should be looking at um
facilities that were cited before the
SEC certificate process was
available cuz I think that's been
brought up in conversations that I've
been privy to and I'm just wondering
whether they're whether that might be
beneficial in the
language thanks for your question
um you know if that is a concern on a
given facility to which this might apply
there might be some way
to um suggest that if that is the case
that there there be a recognition of uh
of the appropriate
review and I follow up and I think um my
understanding of why that's being
brought up is that there may be existing
um facilities that have never gone
through a fome process and so even
though they'd be applying for a FasTrack
they would still hopefully need to you
know pass through the same Gauntlet as
other plants that have had SEC
certification
since thank you perhaps I me this is
this is um
you know I mean it's to as I if I just
made kind of my mind of just thinking
about it that um we I think New
Hampshire has done a you know the
department of environmental service and
the other folks who need to look at the
environmental review do a very good job
um I would like to think that this
process here suggests when does it
become necessary to do what and
that I brought this spill for because I
am deeply concerned with our coming
electrification and the to the extent we
can de decarbonizing certain aspects of
the economy or transition to to um lower
CO2 impact fuels and then you know as
we're all know where we're moving and
with the hydrogen and battery storage
and officer I mean all all this and
solar you know um that that we be able
to get there and and and I just think
that's so important I think that's why I
I keep repeating 281 609 this bill New
Hampshire needs to be at a place where
it can
achieve the benefits to our consumers of
a more reliable cheaper I think supplies
of of energy and be able to provide a
process where investors and federal
grants can can come into the
state and I I mean you know as long as
I've been thinking about these issues
this is back to the 7
um you know the the potential for us to
transition and to get cheaper supplies
of of energy into the state we have
often had a lot of problems over that
whether it's generation or transmission
and sometimes with good reason you know
some bad things were proposed um and
sometimes and and so on but uh we got to
protect the taxpayers but we we've got
to be able to we've got to be able to
get this energy transition moving we
have the we have the ability here with
some existing fac facilities that could
really be leveraged and advantaged to
help us in this process and that's why
this bill's here and I would I would it
would really I think be very despairing
for all of us who share these energy
goals and investment goals to see that
we create a FastTrack process which
really isn't a fast trck and that's
that follow up yep so that I mean I
share all your concerns and I think
we're all looking to figure out how we
can uh assist with transition and it
makes that all makes perfect sense I
guess the question is just to the
specific aims of the language in this
bill whether or not there needs to be
any type of distinction between plants
that have already undergone an SEC
process for fast tracking and plants
that never have whether they're all in
the same category in terms of us wanting
to be able to to FastTrack them or
whether there should be some distinction
for those that haven't had the benefit
of Dees or anyone looking at the aspects
that have been looked at your question
let me just give one last little take on
that I I being very much a pragmatist I
would rather than try to create some
language that carves out just what are
we talking about in a not review and so
on to have it be that this adequate
language that in a the case by case
basis that is the proposal that would
help determine as we see in the first
part of this bill the F of the app
apption all the things that has to do
right there that that to me it seems
would cover the questions that are
raised about whether it's had adequate
review before and that would be part of
the the process so maybe a little slight
language that recognizes that but I I
don't I I would not think a separate
attempt to try to Define what's in
what's out would would would be very
very practical I I'm not just not sure
how we do it so existing is the larger
bucket and it also it contains SEC
approved and non SEC C certified is what
you're saying existing just means if if
it's there we'll
see I mean you know you there's a lot of
wisdom in this committee and I I think
if this is an issue you'll work on
it representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you m uh
Senator once again and I know you're a
busy man you've got places to go and so
I won't be labor at the point but uh and
you you might repeat some of the things
you just said but what you did recognize
that one of the likely sticking points
would be defining public interest uh and
so as somebody who's a pragmatist and
and is known for balancing different
interests could you leave us some
thoughts as to what you think the public
interest might be thanks for your
question um you know I I think I haven't
had a chance to look at this but I think
we probably have some pretty good
definition of a public interest in
existing statute and existing energy
stat maybe there'd be a way to reference
that um my own feeling is that the
public interest is that we in this state
is we all we want to keep costs low we
want to take care of the the the the the
consumer and we um recognize that there
are um you know certain goals in terms
of uh pollution and environmental issues
that's public interest as well and I
personally think of there's a compelling
public interest that New Hampshire be
able to participate in the energy
way echoing uh representative kaplan's
comment that that you're a busy man and
you uh need to move on and also that
there are other people who want to
testify I want to ask you to give us one
last thought uh before we let you go and
that is
this since it looks like the Senate is
probably going to pass HB
609 and between 281 and 609 we now have
a fairly sign significantly changed SEC
process in place do we need to give that
process time to prove that it works
before we make further changes to the
process that's kind of a philosophical
question and I'd love to hear your take
on it thank you Mr chairman you know
frankly I think that this bill if we
pass it and the projects that might
arise from it will actually be the the
test case or the proof as to whether 281
and 609 will work because these are
likely to be the first ones that come
forward and there's a timeliness issue
here too that that money in the IR act
those
investors that money can just flow quite
nicely to other states and to other
projects and um I think would be just
really really harmful to the to the
consumers in the state if we couldn't
take advantage of that funding and um so
I I mean I think I think we'll get what
we want in terms of the SEC process how
does it work do we do the right thing
when we when the projects that would be
affected by 451 come forth cuz they're
going to be first in line M as far as I
could tell so that's my answer okay
great answer thank you and thank you
senator for introducing this legislation
to us thank you let's move along now and
hear from some other folks who I'm sure
have uh important perspectives to shed
some light on this legislation let's
hear next from James Andrews of granite
Shore power in
st& thank you chairman BOS morning
morning committee members uh my name is
James Andrews I'm president and CEO of
granite Shore power and bo uh testifying
in favor of s SP
451 as an asset owner and developer I
hope my views on the sighting process
will be helpful and illustrate how
sighting reforms May accelerate the
sighting success and completion of clean
energy projects we all seek to
advance if New Hampshire is going to
benefit from the energy transition and
clean alternative energy opportunities
not only decarbonization efforts but
also economic growth it is imperative
that the state encourage Capital be
invested directly in New Hampshire to
support infrastructure projects that
starts with an efficient sighting
process granted Shore Powers generating
stations are essential resources within
ISO New England assuring reliability
reliable electricity to the families and
businesses of New Hampshire when needed
most our generating Fleet serves an as
an essential Bridge transforming to the
next generation of energy resources in
New Hampshire from our earliest days
gsp's message has been consistent and
clear we strongly support such a
transition and will play an important
role providing power to businesses and
families in our region during that
process and
Beyond the question is how do we get
over this imaginary bridge and execute
the transition that is so
anticipated there is an abundance of
projects developers are seeking to move
forward with that are aligned with grid
transition and the electrification of
the economy the iso New England
interconnection queue is replete with
interconnection requests for wind solar
and Battery
projects from a policy standpoint the
inflation reduction act or IRA has
created attractive tax and borrowing
incentives clearly these projects are
penciling out and there is an urgency to
get them done but why then are so few
being completed in my opinion the
sighting process lacks efficiency
creating time delays and adding risk to
projects that may otherwise be avoided
particularly for sites with existing
infrastructure I have said before New
Hampshire is well suited to take
advantage of the energy transition
opportunities New Hampshire has highly
qualified trade professionals and
educational institutions a favorable tax
climate to compete for the businesses
that will support these projects and
most importantly it's existing major
infrastructure necessary to transition
the region to the next generation of
energy resources and finally got across
that bridge if New Hampshire is serious
about advancing clean energy projects
within the state it is imperative this
legislation be Advanced to make the
sighting process more efficient for
sites with existing or adjacent
infrastructure that are best suited for
critical projects that may be completed
quickly with the enactment of the IR and
the continued shift toward an
electrified economy developing OnDemand
generation resources is more feasible
now than ever to assure electric
reliability for new
englanders development at Legacy sites
will greatly enhance the utilization of
existing interconnection at the
facilities and Advance the Region's
overall generation mix and not
inadvertently kill projects that we all
seek to be completed we strongly support
pass passage of this legislation and
thank the bill sponsors and co-sponsors
for their
leadership thank you for the opportunity
to provide our views and I'll now take
any questions you may have questions for
Mr
Andrews representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Mr Andrews for
taking my question um I'm just curious
curious if if at this point Granite
Shore is is poised to actually present
uh one of these FastTrack projects if
you're actually in a in a position where
you would be looking to come in front of
the commission with it yeah I think it's
fair to say uh representative that since
uh first days of ownership we've been
looking at projects and are now poised
uh to to move forward with projects um
very early on in my tenure I took a trip
to Denmark with uh Ambassador sweat
looked at offshore wind projects and how
that may impact uh you know New England
region and and New Hampshire
specifically given our advantages um and
we've looked at a lot of things and and
we are poised and ready to move
forward thank you additional questions
Vice chair Thomas thank Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um I'll kind
of ask you the same question I asked
Senator Waters but I'll ask you
differently in terms of investors what
type of in of efficiency are they
looking for to come to New Hampshire are
we looking in terms of a timeline are we
looking at something that's 25% quicker
50% quicker uh what what's your take on
that I I think it's more a matter of uh
drisking uh the process for Capital
right now the the process is so lengthy
uh and and so cumbersome uh for new
sites that frankly
as you put forth a project and you put
forth the economics you put forth the
technology by the time you get through
the SEC process a lot of those things
have changed and you have to go back and
you you're in frankly this endless loop
and you can never get a project done
because that process is too long um so
it it it really comes down to drisking
the timeline right Capital moves pretty
pretty quickly with speed uh when it's
committed so uh enabling that to happen
I think is is a is a is a wise thing to
questions representative licki has a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question Mr Andrews uh
you mentioned on demand and which I
could you be more specific as to which
types of energy can be done on demand uh
you know whether um
and uh because that's a real sticking
point for a lot of us because if it
really truly is not on demand then it's
not um you know basically we still need
the base
load uh I think what you're finding is
there's there's going to be a
significant need for on demand
resources uh with the renewable uh Basel
load facilities that we expect to come
online Senator Waters mentioned uh the
offshore wind lease areas uh bom is
going forward with uh you know this fall
uh and and those facilities out there on
demand resources would be things like
battery storage or quick start CTS that
when those are unable to uh function uh
as that base load there's going to be
something that's going to need to
supplant that uh very quickly uh and
those are the type of resources uh on
demand resources that we're talking
question uh thank you Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question
um if you're talking about Renewables I
don't know how you could be talking
about Basel load the output from
Renewables Is
Random so you know you can build a
battery system on top of that I mean I
guess maybe that's what you're talking
about but I mean to talk about
Renewables and base load in the same
sentence I think is an
error maybe you misunderstood my my
comment cuz uh wind and solar are
inherently not reliable right those
aren't on demand resources uh it takes
the wind or it takes the sun to shine
what I'm talking about are resources
that support those types of resources
that enable those projects to happen uh
but also in a in a carbon neutral
way follow up so to be clear you're
talking about energy storage you're
talking about batteries or something
else pumped Hydro who knows what um
specifically
uh energy storage from a but also uh
there are you know Green LNG uh or green
gas uh turbines that can be used that
well representative lii has another
question thank you this is more of a
followup to my previous question um what
is the state of Battery Technology I
know I had co-workers from a previous
job who went to work for Ambry and
locked Martin and so far I haven't seen
anything come from those is there any
true battery grid scale
storage there is uh there's a number of
grid grid scale storage projects uh
country representative Kennedy has
another question yeah my last one thank
you Mr chairman um you you said you have
a project that's ready to go what is
it uh that is a battery storage
project
additional
questions seeing none we want to thank
you Mr Andrews for being here all right
appreciate it thank you okay next we'll
hear from Nick coff of the conservation
back
hey good morning um my name is Nick cof
with the conservation law Foundation
thanks for having me here this morning
um I agree with the chief sponsor uh
Senator Waters that we need to reform
existing sighting laws to support clean
energy infrastructure development in the
state um I guess I have several concerns
with with the bill I'm going to address
them here this morning um f first off
under the bill um the powering of an
existing facility would be subject to
this new expedited sighting track and um
you this could result in the repowering
of an existing fossil fuel plant with
another type of fossil fuel so like a
coal plant with natural gas or something
um which could result in significant
environmental impacts U particularly
emissions water impacts Etc and so you
know where there's a potential for you
know the significant impacts like this
um I think it behooves us to to really
limit this expon track to to clean
energy technologies that have um lesser
environmental impacts and impacts in
general um and you know as as
representative McGee said a few minutes
ago I agree that there is a concern
about um facilities that were
constructed in the
1960s um before the current sighting law
was enacted that have not been through
the rigor of the existing sighting
process and so it is a concern that some
some of those older
facilities um went went through a
process before most environmental laws
were were even passed so the 1960s was
was before many um of the key
environmental laws were passed that
those facilities might be modified
without really going through the full
rigor of a sec process um under this
expedited
track second um I wanted to address the
public interest standard that's um
required under the um under s451 as a by
the
Senate um for for an application for the
expedited sighting track there's this
public interest required public interest
finding on page
two um lines 26 or sorry lines 29
through
32 and I think that needs to be better
defined and clarified I would suggest
using the definition of public interest
that is in RSA 162 H1 that has some
criteria there that's the existing
sighting law um that has some criteria
there for public interest I think it's a
pretty well balanced um standard for
what public interest is and I think
public interest is kind of an a morphous
context without a clear definition I
think if you pull a members of this
committee you could get 20 different
definitions of public interest so I
think providing some clarifications on
that definition would be helpful um and
along those lines I think there should
be a means for parties that are
negatively impacted by this expedited
setting track to to challenge that um
and I I think you could apply RSA 541
which provides some um some due process
protections for for potentially agreed
Parties By by the EXA sighting track
under this public interest standard um
and then but lastly I just wanted to
address something that Senator Waters
said about the sort of interconnection
versus name plate capacity
standard with name plate capacity it's
it's pretty easy to find what that means
I can spend one minute do one minute of
research find out what the name plate
capacity is for CBR station for marac
station Etc um with interconnection
capacity I you know it's that's hard to
find that's not publicly accessible that
information so I don't really know what
we're getting with with that if if we go
with interconnection capacity is that is
that a huge increase over name plate
capacity or is it the same it's it's
just not there's no transparency with
that definition and so I think before we
change that definition around to
interconnection capacity we need to
think about how we can ensure there's
transparency so that we know what we're
getting with with this potential bill um
those are all my comments happy to
answer anybody's questions and happy to
work with sponsors and all of you all to
try to improve this Bill thank you thank
you good comments we appreciate those
crof representative Thomas has one thank
you very much Mr chair and thank you Mr
cof for being here it's good to see you
up and about um I I see with this bill
there are a lot of uh there's public
input um however in the application the
the uh items that are included in the
application there's nothing that that
specifically addresses uh public input
I'm not talking about public interest
but input which can include things like
roads neighborhoods and potential toxins
would you be open to including that as
part of the application going forward
yeah but I I think there should be some
opportunity to at least comment on the
application you know whether meets the
public interest standard um I understand
that you don't want to create a lengthy
process but at least some opportunity to
comment uh whether in written comments
or um verbal comments I think would be
helpful to to ensure that those voices
are heard thank you additional questions
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr Koff good to see you
again um I uh take um the sponsors point
that we have to have flexibility in a
allowing um businesses to figure out
what composite of energy transition is
going to make their plant work um but I
was wondering in the definition around
public interest whether we might include
specific language about lowering harmful
emissions in terms of a transition that
benefits the public because it it gets
us off an emissions curve that you know
has been going up um so I wonder what
what you think about us having any type
of specific language in that regard
because I think if there was a need to
do combined cycle or or some type of
energy solution that included Renewables
but also had some other um some other
components uh rather than saying it has
to be clean or nothing we could say as
long as it significantly lowers right
the TR the point of the transition is to
lower emissions so do you think there
should be language in here that is
specifically alludes to that yeah I mean
I think it'd be helpful to have language
like that that ensures that um you know
the impacts of emissions are are lesser
than than current you know what exists
currently um and I think that's one way
to do it I mean I think you can play
around with the public interest criteria
162 H1 but yeah I think that would be
that further
questions okay seeing none let's get the
perspective of the
existing site evaluation committee we'll
call on the administrator of the SEC
Drew
Beamer good morning
you today I'm here to to share my
perspective on Senate Bill
451 a measure aimed at streamlining the
process for repowering retrofiting or
repurposing existing sites particularly
those under the jurisdiction of the site
evaluation committee or those predating
its
establishment I want to start by
emphasizing my Firm support for the core
principles of SB
451 as someone deeply immersed in these
processes I understand the critical need
for simplifying
them um especially in the realm of
advancing sustainable energy initiatives
the idea of
modernizing outdated generation
facilities resonates strongly with me
and I commend the efforts to facilitate
such transitions initially my position
on SB 451 was very straightforward I
think I just said I like it three words
in the Senate however as the bill
progressed through the public hearing to
the executive session there was an
amendment that significantly reduced the
timelines outlined within the
legislation and while I remain a
proponent of streamlining processes in
general I have reservations about the
potential impact of the bill as amended
on public engagement it's vital that we
afford the public ample time and
opportunity to participate in these
discussions additionally I'm personally
grappling with ambiguity of the term
repowering that we've mentioned earlier
here today clear and precise legislative
language is essential to ensure that
your intent Endo across future
generations of regulators and
administrations in tandem with our
discussions on SB 451 House Bill 609 is
on the brink of becoming
law thanks to the dedicated efforts of
this committee and your counterparts in
the Senate House Bill 609 represents a
significant stride towards efficiency by
reallocating existing Personnel
Resources instead of creating new ones a
true embodiment of the small government
New Hampshire way while I have
confidence in our ability meaning my
ability to implement any devised system
I urge caution in hastening the
adjustment of Permitting
timelines let us perhaps first navigate
the Post House Bill 609 landscape before
revisiting this aspect of the
legislation it's crucial to remember
that Simplicity does not always equate
to speed
in conclusion I reiterate my support for
the overarching goals of this bill while
advocating for prudence and Clarity in
its execution thank you for your
attention and I'd love to take any
questions
excellent questions for Mr Beamer
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Beamer good to see
you here thanks for taking my question
okay so you're alluding to um concerns
around the
expedit timelines that appear throughout
the bill the 60-day to 30-day the 90day
right they're all kind of chopped in
half Are there specific areas of the SEC
process that are outlined here where you
think that the numbers that have been
attributed are too scant and need in
other words are there specific ones that
you believe that you cannot accomplish
within the number that set on the page
that need to be expanded uh it's it's
not necessarily about believing that I
can or can't accomplish them I'm pretty
confident that we can accomplish
anything that that you folks devise the
issue is that uh from a public
perspective um I think that the public
um in the sort of cascading way that
these permits
unfold um we need to make sure that they
have ample time to weigh in in the
process and I'm just envisioning in my
mind the 45 day timeline to have a
public meeting for the SEC and my
opinion on the matter is that um there's
no such thing as too much public input
um anybody who wants to weigh in should
be given every opportunity to do so and
I'm envisioning a scenario where perhaps
40 days into a 45 day timeline uh we get
back something from you know Sister
agency that's a key component of the
permitting and then the public has five
days to ostensibly read something before
formulating a uh coherent opinion so um
I'm not saying that that will happen I'm
saying that it could happen and um in my
experience as far as speed goes um if
we're looking at this as an expedited
process I'm wholly supportive of the
idea of you got 10 boxes to check let's
cut it down to five if you're taking a
coal plant you're turning it into
something Greener and cleaner uh with
similar base load capacity let's take
those 10 let's chop it down to five make
it easier but easier does not
automatically mean faster and and I'm
confident in my agency's ability to
expedite anything I am just um putting
my public participation hat on which is
kind of the world I came from before I
was here so
um you know if there was a if there was
an extremely compelling reason to
shorten the timelines I'm
certainly you know amable to listening
but um at this juncture I just
personally wouldn't do it followup Mr
chair followup so the followup would be
then what can we do to make this bill
better because we are not the experts
you are in terms of the timeline in
terms of your concerns around the
timeline not that you can't do the job
but that the public interest might be
better served if there was greater
flexibility or if there were some
aspects uh of us chopping stuff in half
that we're not quite half so I know that
what would you recommend I think any
timeline by definition is kind of going
to be arbitrary I mean we have a
365 day timeline for things and and
that's not because it takes exactly 300
65 days um but what I will say is that
the original uh incarnation of this bill
before amended and I am spacing out on
if there were other substantive things
in the amendment but the thing I'm
focusing on is the timelines when I
showed up at the Senate and I said I
like it okay uh that was based on the
timelines as outlined in the original
legislation and then the amendment that
dropped um before the bill got exec
chopped those in half so I would say
since like I said all timelines by
Nature are arbitrary I would prefer to
revert to the ones that were in the
original
bill vice chair Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so this goes back to a
comment made by a previous testifier
saying that uh having these shorter
timelines was um he didn't say critical
but in my words would be important and
critical to Capital investors as whether
they spend their money here or take it
elsewhere where so where do you
see the middle ground here in terms of
having something that investors see is
not a quagmire so they go somewhere else
and yet leaving the public enough time
to comment and in addition you know a a
tag on that question would be is what
the example you use of someone of
something coming in at the last minute
and therefore public having less time to
take a look at it where's the where's
the safeguards to guarantee against that
being used against perhaps a project
being done by someone or some entity
keep putting in new information at the
last minute and you keep extending the
timeline so the public has more input
all of that I think should be blended
into what's the happy medium on this
absolutely um I'll also draw your
attention to a another piece of
testimony that was that is also probably
contrary to my opinion but it's worth um
finding in the in for the sake of uh uh
compromise here is um I believe it was
Senator
Waters mentioned the fact that there may
be some Ira timelines inflation
reduction act timelines that that may
theoretically mesh up with things and I
think that's something that that we
should certainly look at the Timeline
that I'm familiar with that's not
necessarily gerine to this specific bill
was when the Twin State energy project
was still um theoretically a possibility
I was waiting through the grant process
to apply for some money that would help
in um The Blocking and tackling of um
helping the SEC come to a decision more
rapidly being the idea um so I'm
familiar there were timelines attached
to that there maybe timelines attached
to other things I think it would be
prudent for folks to follow up with um
Senator Waters as far as the drisking
investment component here is
um looking at it from a regulatory
perspective um and phrasing it like um
making the process more clear um I don't
personally see the timeline as being a
impediment to investment I see
uncertainty with what can happen during
that timeline as being an impediment to
investment um I see if you necessarily
correlated a longer timeline with more
opportunity for people to show up and
throw monkey wrenches into the process
then then that would be of
concern um that's not necessarily
concern of mine though my concern is um
is making sure that the public is
engaged fully and thoroughly I've found
that in the instances in these type of
situations when you short change the
public in the name of expediency even if
you um doing it you know for altruistic
reasons or you know for what you think
are good reasons you can create some
strategic issues for yourself down the
road because when people feel like
they're not heard they tend to get
louder not quieter so um I apologize for
giving you a roundabout answer there I
think it's a valid question um clearly
I'm I'm not an investor but um the um I
think the risk is
more um tied to the actual known steps
that you have to take and whether or not
somebody can move the goalposts on you
than whether it's 90 days or 45
days followup thank you for the followup
so uh I agree with you uh in in what you
were describing so in other words what
I'm hearing you say is that under the
new criteria for the SEC and their
flexibility to um evaluate these uh
these things that you feel the SEC has
the tools now that they can navigate
through all those pitfalls that you had
mentioned I think we can
because the SEC as we sit here today is
just myself and I have the ability to
cooperate with sister agencies and
they've been incredible um in
cooperation um doe Dees phenomenal
phenomenal uh work that they've done to
make my life easier um the issue is as
far as my actual resources that I have
dedicated to my mission is zero people
it's just myself um so if we move me
over to the Pu proper I become a Force
multiplier for the Pu they can hand me
some things that are pertinent to rate
cases and other things they have going
on but going the other direction I can
call upon their staff personnel which
could be an analyst or an attorney when
there's a big permitting project coming
down the line and um that's a very very
good position for me to be in this next
year under house bill 609 or this this
next you know
um I'm just sort of thinking before the
next legislative session when we have a
year under our belt I think that um you
know we based on the projects that I
anticipate in the queue um now that Twin
States is probably not going to happen
it'll be a good dry run and a good test
for us to see whether the processes and
the uh structure outlined in 9 work and
I have confident that they will because
I've done a handful of things by and
large by myself for the past couple
years and when you add more resources to
the mix especially ones from an agency
that already has them I I like where
that puts me a
lot representative Thomas also has a
question thank you Mr chair um I'm going
to preface this question by saying that
I come from St gobain land um if with
this rushed timeline a permit and I
don't even know if you're the right
person to ask this but if with this
rushed permit uh I mean rushed timeline
a permit is granted and then we find out
that perhaps they were not truthful or
there was um uh subjects that were not
considered or information was not
available what protections does the
State of New Hampshire have for that I
honestly do not know the answer to that
question thank you
apologies
further questions representative Kennedy
has
one thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um uh like
representative Thomas I'm not sure if
you're the right person to ask this
question but I I had a question about
the same thing that has bothered several
people which is in the the first
paragraph where it's talking about
expansion and it says expansion of such
facilities shall be no larger than the
existing facility's name plate capacity
and shall be located at the existing
facility's physical location
or a budding parcel so when I'm when I'm
listening to people Senator Waters and
other people I mean it's clear to me
that expansion and repowering is not
what this is about this is about
replacement it's about replacement of a
current facility with either wind or
solar and you know I mean it's it's a
little odd to be talking about name
plate capacity since again the output
from those sources is random but you
could take a look at the peak capacity
of a wind farm or whatever
but you know given if that is in fact
the purpose of this part of the bill um
you know the the the idea that you could
replace a coal plant or a gas turbine
with a wind farm or a solar farm on the
same area I think is you know mistaken I
mean those those facilities take a
hundred times the land area of a coal
plant or a gas turbine so you know if
you got a current site I mean I don't
know if it has some gigantic area around
it that is not being used but you know I
can foresee that if if you go down this
road you're not going to have the kind
of space at that site that you would
need so I I don't know how you see what
this paragraph means or how you would
Implement that maybe you could comment
on that well you know trying to stay um
you know objective here to the different
fuel types one of the examples I've
given just to um put it in perspective
is maramax station is what we'd probably
call a small coal plant perhaps a
mediumsized coal plant it's about 500
megawatts I think it's 490 somewhere in
that range and um you can look up online
there are different sources I forget
which one I used but there's a
calculator that you can basically say
how would we replace this with with
something else you know in terms of Base
load capacity or name plate capacity um
if you were to try to replace maramax
station with solar panels under the
current technological world live in
you'd need 3,000 Acres 3500 Acres just
to get the same generation capacity uh
forgetting that that's that that would
be intermittent power so whether or not
you think that's a phenomenal idea or
not I just don't think that that's going
to happen I don't think anybody is going
to attempt to do that I think the far
more likely
scenario is that due to improved
technology or perhaps a legislative
adjustment to what we call
RPS um that you may see things like um
you know Green hydrogen being utilized
something else that comes in a truck or
a pipe that is um uh carbon neutral that
can be utilized in a similar Basel load
uh Power Plant in a similar capacity so
um that's not my opinion that's just
sort of a hypothetical wind turbines too
the installed name plate capacity is
like 3 megawatt you get about one
megawatt so you would need to find a
place to put 500 of those in New
Hampshire to replace maramax station so
I I understand fully the uh the the
concern sir I just don't think that
that's what would happen
followup yeah it's not just the number
of the turbines they have to be spaced
also because they can't interfere with
each other but it sounds like you're
aware of that so I mean do you think
this paragraph needs a
rewrite apologies sir which paragraph
are we looking
at the one that's talking about uh sorry
it's uh it starts uh line five on the
first page on page and the one that's
talking about expansion and repowering
of current
requir I uh something kind of leaped off
the theoretical page to me was
representative Corman I believe
question um which was an extreme
hypothetical but say that you owned an
existing generation site and then bought
a thousand acres around it does that
grandfather in the Thousand Acres for
repowering I I don't know the answer to
that question um I would say generally
rewrite
um Clarity perhaps um I'm just not as I
said my my comments I'm just not fully
um understanding of what the word
repowering is um to me you know looking
at it it sounds pretty straightforward
you're taking a power plant you're
replacing it with a new power plant or
you're hooking up a natural gas pipeline
to maramax station and having it burn
LNG instead of coal um but the ambiguity
that's baked in gives me pause not
because I don't think I could
sufficiently navigate it but because
whatever system we devise has to be
resilient enough for your legislative
intent to
endure multiple generations of
subsequent um government officials so um
I would leave as little up to
imagination as possible that would be my
personal
preference okay great representative
Kaplan has a question thank you Mr chair
and uh thank you for coming in uh this
is a little more pragmatic you mentioned
your concern about public input in in
the process and and the timeline not
allowing that um so specifically would a
90day period for a public hearing be
enough in your opinion rather than a 45
day oh I absolutely I I mean I think so
yeah I think that's a reasonable thing
to do and at this point in time again
hypothesizing the house bill 609 World
um the mechanics of actually scheduling
the meeting would be far easier when
you're trying to get five people in a
room instead of 10 you know so or nine
that okay representative McGee has a
question yeah thanks um actually in the
beginning of your testimony uh Mr Beamer
you used the language uh
retrofitting or repurposing existing
sites and I think that might be more
exact language that we're all trying to
Grapple with than because repurposing or
retrofitting implies that you're going
to be transitioning it from one thing to
another rather than the repowering which
I think people are having difficulty
picturing yeah um I think I Ed those
words because I wanted to sort of um
throw out there that that things that we
perceive to be synonyms may not
necessarily be synonyms and uh
repowering is the one with probably the
most ambiguity repurposing a site could
be tearing down a power plant and making
a a dairy farm I mean you know um but um
retrofitting I think is probably more
clear because my definition of
retrofitting would say um hook up
natural gas to maramax station turn it
into a gas burner
retrofit an existing burner to burn
something else that' be a retrofit
repowering though
[Music]
um that's that's the one I'm not so sure
about representative Ms has a question
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you for
uh coming in I don't know if you heard
my question to um representative Waters
about um why it was that the bill
deletes the ability for a municipality
an
in with an affected facility not to have
a special a separate public hearing do
you have any thoughts on that is that
something that is uh is uh uh meaningful
or does has it gotten in the way in the
past of uh approvals um by separate
public hearing are you referring to the
uh the fact that if it's below a certain
generation threshold it's a municipal
issue and if if it's above a threshold
it's a state
issue because I know there are
components especially with with projects
where you know you have you you were
required to have an SEC meeting in the
county I believe
um but if if it's a transmission line
that goes through multiple counties now
you're having multiple meetings in
towns the the the way the ex and and as
I understand that this is in current
statute that the way it's currently
worded is that um if there is a proposed
facility to be located in a specific
municipality mhm that municipality has
the ability to request a separate public
meeting just for that municipality
separate from the one that that that
needs that is required to be held in the
county and and this bill eliminates the
the ability of a municipality to request
that okay um would it be all right if I
um get a response to that and follow up
with the committee later on because I
don't that
perfectly F
okay all right we need to move along
representative Corman has one final
question yes and this will be quick it's
uh one of the questions I asked Senator
Waters which is about the sequencing of
the public info sessions and then the
SEC public hearing do they need to be in
that
order the info session preceding the
public hearing yes um are are you saying
statutorily or in my opinion
both both um in my opinion the
information should be afforded to the
public before the public hearing so it's
hard to comment on something that you
don't have the information
on okay Mr Beamer thank you very much
appreciate your perspective uh being the
SEC guy and appreciate you being here
today we got to move along though and
I'm going to call up Meredith Hatfield
next to give us the perspective of The
Nature Conservancy
we do want to move on to HB
540 fairly quickly thank you good
morning uh Meredith Hatfield for The
Nature Conservancy um we do agree with
several of the points raised um by Mr
Beamer and clf so I'll try not to repeat
them um we do thank uh Senator Waters
and the um co-sponsors for trying to
ensure that New Hampshire is well
positioned to take advantage of Ira
funding and we agree that we need more
infrastructure um it's our view that um
it should be uh non-emitting um if we
are going to FASTT track it um one
concern that I don't think has been
directly raised is um how the timelines
might impact the other agencies um so I
think it would be because Dees does play
such an important role in sighting it
would be good to hear from Dees if they
can meet these timelines and if they
might um conflict with other laws or um
with Federal permitting
requirements uh we agree with respect to
whether um the FasTrack should be um
tied to name plate capacity versus
interconnection for the reasons that clf
um articulated we also agree that um it
shouldn't apply to sites that haven't
already been through the SEC
process
um repowering I believe is potentially a
term of Art and there might be um a
useful definition at ISO New England or
in some other similar regulatory process
that perhaps we could look to for that
um we weren't clear if it applies to
transmission um we don't have a view on
whether it does but I think when I first
read this I was thinking Generation Um
that and we do agree also with um a
concern about striking allowing um a
municipality or an unincorporated place
that might be impacted by a project um
to to not allow them to request a public
information
session and then a very technical
question on um page one line 12 um I
didn't know if that I think I'm confused
because that's says 162 H7 but later
there are references to
h7a so I think um perhaps Mr
Monahan um knows how to how to answer my
question so I can I can ask him um and I
think those were uh all of the comments
that we had that were additional thank
you those are good catches thank you any
questions for Miss
Hatfield seeing none thanks
again and please do consult with Mr
Monahan about that other question uh Mr
Monahan has submitted a pin card he's
willing to answer questions if there are
any he has no testimony to deliver but
is willing to answer questions does
anyone have a question for Mr
monan representative
McGee yeah I think we'd like to get the
clarity about um I think I have an
understanding of why on page four line
three section
1B um the piece for municipalities was
removed but perhaps you can answer
representative M's question around why
that was taken out uh yes and I guess it
gets fundamentally uh the the approach
of the bill um as many members of the
committee know was it last summer or two
summers ago uh you met to try to uh
figure out a better way to get a to get
a better set evaluation committee
process uh one of the observations was
that uh we had exact we have a one- siiz
fits-all so for northern pass that had
to go through 31 towns you have the
exactly the same process as a a facility
that wants to do an expansion or or
repowering so this was an approach to
change that the theory here is that
because we are limiting this fast track
to uh existing facilities the community
already knows that there's a power plant
there uh and that uh it will be sized to
to the uh the internet connection or the
name plate or whatever might be worked
out and so having the uh underlying
public hearing process that includes you
know the applicant having a um a
pre-application process then the site
evaluation committee undertaking its U
public hearing and then each of the
agencies having their own public process
seem to be a
reasonable um amount of public input
because it's an existing facility um and
because what we're trying to do is get
to an answer to representative Thomas's
question the current process require is
a 14-month process to get through the
site evaluation committee process what
we're attempting to do here is to get it
to about seven months um which gets to
Mr Andrews concerns about the ability to
attract Capital uh drisk projects um
things like that so in answer to
represent Mon's questions the thought is
that the current the community is well
aware of it uh it's the
applicant uh when they make their
application they they would consult the
local community for the public hearing
process so uh so in an effort to make
the process uh swifter there was a
consolidation of that um public hearing
process representative Ms has a question
so um thank you for um for that
clarification I I I guess
the I don't know if it's really a
question but maybe the push back would
be that um you know if um if there's a
project in Rockham County if there's a
project in Hampton for example um I I
wouldn't expect that every
Community every individual town in
rockim County should be able to have a
public hearing um because
one one meeting that covers the whole
County would certainly be appropriate
but I do think that the any that the
that the the town that's hosting this
facility should have the right the
privilege if you will to have a separate
meeting in their town to make it as
convenient as possible for the people in
that town to ask their questions because
they are the ones that are the most
directly impacted so I'm I'm struggling
still still struggling with why the
language is taken out I think that's
fair and there's probably an easy way to
address that without adding time to the
system uh and that's because these are
existing facilities I don't think you NE
have to rely on the county which was you
know Legacy legislation so perhaps the
the that public information session
should take place in the community in
which the current facility
exists but of course any municipality is
free to intervene uh at the site
valuation committee they often
do followup you need a followup okay so
I you know but I think that's what we
want to try to avoid right having uh
municipalities intervene in a in a in a
legal way I mean that that really slows
the process and that's what the public
information process is for is so that
prior to the application being made
folks participate in it so I know I
appreciate representative V you have out
to do I'm happy to participate in it you
know I'm the uh the architect of this
and so I'm happy to answer any questions
work with the committee but honestly I
think the goal is to try over the this
process is to get to yes on this so we
have a system that we can point to those
who want to invest in New Hampshire to
say we have taken some steps to make it
quicker uh the goal here uh was not to
eliminate uh the uh environmental
permitting or the other processes that
take place within uh in the process it
was a matter of more efficient timelines
for existing facilities so okay
representative Kaplan gets the last
question thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you Mr
Monahan uh just following up with the
idea of increasing the 45-day period for
a public hearing to a 90day hearing what
is your opinion on that and how would
that fit into your expedited process the
underlying Theory here is that we're
trying to have a swifter system for
facilities that already exists uh and
that uh it's really incumbent upon the
applicant to make that process work so
that people feel informed and they're a
part of the process and so uh the reason
we change we suggesting it change from
uh 90 to 45 days is so that we can have
a quicker bureaucratic process uh with
while at the same time respecting the uh
the role of public import um we're
comfortable with that because we are
talking about uh modifications or
changes to facilities that already exist
well it looks like we have a lot to
discuss in our work session on this bill
and I sincerely hope that you'll be able
to be here when we have that work
session I haven't scheduled it yet so I
can't tell you when it is but y uh
unless it's at the same hour as the
eclipse um I will be here but uh I'll
try not to schedule it for that hour but
I but I must say I have everyone who's
testified today I have been in touch
with we've I've shared draft amendments
um I think um uh we will not necessarily
if it's okay with you uh continue to
work with stakeholders to uh narrow the
issues so that when we do get to a work
session uh there's some more there's
some agreement uh about how to approach
all this well now you know what our
concerns are so that'll work well great
all right so thank you we're going to
close the public hearing then on Senate
Bill 451 and we're going to turn around
very quickly and open a public hearing
on Senate Bill 540 and here to introduce
the bill to us for on behalf of Senator
Lang is dy
Fett who is the U Senate Aid I believe
for Senator Lang so Dy welcome good to
see you again and thank you for being
here good to see you as well good
morning chairman Vose and members of the
committee my name is Daley Fett and I'm
the Senate majority caucus director I'm
here to introduce s sp540 on behalf of
Senator Lang as amended by the senate
senate Bill 540 would require the
department of energy to investigate ways
to facilitate both behind the meter
energy storage and utility scale energy
storage in New Hampshire the
investigation would be divided into two
portions the first would be focused on
residential behind the meter storage
with a report due December 30th of 2025
and the second focused on utility scale
storage with a due date of December 30th
of
2026 the Senate amended the bill by
adding in the requirement that one the
department specifically consider how
public policy can best establish
accurate and efficient price signals for
energy storage projects that avoid
actual transmission and distribution
costs or reduce wholesale electricity
market prices and two the best way to
encourage both utility and non-utility
investments in energy storage
projects the amendment also added in the
reporting dates uh in December 2025 and
December 2026 and that the bill will
take effect upon passage Senator Lang
thanks you for your consideration of s
sp540 thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak this morning and if
you have any questions I can either
bring them to Senator Lang and make sure
you all get an answer I also believe the
department of energy is here who can
also answer any questions that you
have excellent thank you for introducing
this legislation any questions from the
committee representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr fette for coming in uh I just
have a quick quick question it seems to
be that this is amending a statute that
set up a a report to be issued this year
this August I believe so why why the EXT
ition it seems to me that this bill
basically just extends the report that
was already due yeah I actually don't
know the answer to that question but
I'll be happy to get back to you after I
talk to sen thank you we'll be hearing
from the doe in just a minute they may
have the answer to that question any
other questions for Mr
fette seeing none well thank you thank
you very much chair please say hi to
Senator Lang for us and next we'll hear
from Josh Elliot of the uh Department of
En
welcome good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record Josh
Elliott director of the division of
policy and programs with the New
Hampshire Department of energy um as Mr
fet uh summarized the bill quite well um
essentially this has the department
taking on sort of a dual track
investigation first of looking at um
behind the meter storage and then
looking at utility scale storage uh
through our um investigatory process um
with those um dates of having a report
due by December 30th 2025 for the
initial one and then uh the report for
the utility scale storage due by
December 30th of 2026 um I have a
testimony letter that is coming around
realizing that you've heard a lot today
um I'm happy to stop and take any
questions the committee may have um
about uh the bill before
you
okay questions from the
committee representative
McGee hi thank you for being here um
thank you for your testimony I when I
first took a look at the bill I I it I
noticed that in the analysis where it
says uh the bill requires the department
of energy to investigate ways to
facilitate um I I wondered if facilitate
uh was the right place to stop in terms
of modifying what it is that you're
doing with the investigation is it to
facilitate adoption of or to
facilitate
um you know the benefit like I just feel
like it it stops a little short of
defining what you're going to be doing
although I think the bill does have some
good detail in it um thank you for the
question representative um yes so in
it's sort of a dual not to use the Dual
track uh um phrase again um but
essentially how to facilitate those um
actually a through F of what are we
looking at here right what are we
um and I think you we can look at um uh
subset on line 11 and 12 how public
policy can best establish accurate and
effic efficient price signals for energy
storage projects um how to best
encourage both utility and non-utility
investments in storage projects so
there's acknowledgement um not explicit
but certainly implicit if you're looking
through the duties here of energy
storage is a good tool in the toolkit
how can we make sure that it is um um
operating efficiently within New
Hampshire and what are those public
policy choices um that need to be
structured around those to ensure that
so followup follow up so are we to
determine that if we pass this bill into
legislation that by the end of 2025 in
the end of 2026 you will be giving us
um actionable information in order for
us to move forward with legislation or
programs that should be implemented in
order to address each of these thank you
for the question um yes if if through
the purp uh through the course of the
investigation there are clear statutory
hurdles whether it's you know what have
you in terms of in terms of either sting
sighting battery storage or um or citing
it or um either efficient price signals
and things like that that need clear
either legislative Direction on I think
that would be included as part of those
investigations presented to this
committee as well as your colleagues and
other committees um for uh um for
consideration if the the legislature
would want to move forward with such a
policy and the last TI I'll have is any
of this um actually going to dovetail
along with the climate action plan that
Dees is working on because I just keep
wondering how the connections work in
terms of what we're pursuing and why
thank you for the question um we have
been working with our colleagues at um
Environmental Services regarding their
peap uh uh their climate action plan um
there are references to storage in it
this Genesis was actually of this bill
came prior to that um but I don't see
them as working in conflict with one
another representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Elliott um as I asked the
previous speaker I'm GNA repeat my
question to you it seems like 374 H3
came into effect August 2022 and that
was uh mandating a report that would
have been due in two years what happened
to that report and how does that tie
into this extension thank you very much
for the question representative that's
an excellent question um two main
factors um the first of which the
original study did not allow the
department to hire any Consultants or
get any any additional help in terms of
actually moving this forward um battery
storage is not something that the
department necessarily has in-house
expertise on and we would have to rely
on consultants in order to be able to
help move forward the process both as on
the engagement side as well as sort of
those the the very technical details
that would be um contemplated including
engineering standards and things like
that um the second um we had a pair of
bills pass which you're I'm sure you're
all familiar with with the bipar
infrastructure law and the inflation
reduction act so a lot of Staff time has
been devoted to working through those
applications working through all the
thought process um behind standing up
all those the multitude of programs that
are included as part of that um Senator
Waters um uh is a particular proponent
of battery storage we worked with him in
the Senate to make sure that we could
sort of refresh this process get it
moving forward again and give the
department the the resources to be able
investigation representative muns has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for coming back to our committee um I I
had some questions about language that
um was changed or deleted from the
existing statute by this bill um the
first question was um
the the bill you know uses a term
utility scale energy storage as opposed
and as opposed to front- ofth meter
storage which is in current statue
what's the difference um that thank you
for the question that is a good question
uh regarding um they could be really
interchangeable um utility scale storage
um I think provides a little bit of a
better definition of what exactly are we
talking about these would be Merchant
projects um similar to uh a generation
station uh in terms of scale um and
would be participating in the market
that way they' be participating as part
of bidding into the ice New England um
process for capacity um whereas um front
of the meter sort of a little is a
little bit more vague but um I it just
provided a little bit more definition to
what exactly we're talking about and
followup followup and in in existing
statute it it talks about um that the
department shall investigate
uh for both utility and non-utility
owned energy storage projects does this
bill limit it to just utility owned um
it does not um the the second the second
study if you will the second
investigation um references utility
scale um I'm just double checking to
make sure um actually is contemplated
actually in line one of page two to
encourage both utility and private
sector
Investments
okay additional questions representative
bernardy has
one thank you Mr chairman so the uh the
fiscal note as well as the last part of
the bill uh references assessing
electric distribution utilities for the
cost of doing these studies so
um can
you uh I guess
explained how you came up with that that
costing and
why these costs should
be uh levied on the distribution
utilities thank you for the question
representative uh so the cost estimate
was done based on similar investigations
obviously no investigation isn't
identical based on the uh contents that
it seeks to examine um but we've got a
pretty good uh idea of roughly how much
these investigations cost um the figure
that's quoted in the fiscal not is
probably a little bit on the higher end
but we'd rather come in with the higher
end so you know exactly the committee
can and as well as your colleagues in in
house finance know exactly what the cost
um could potentially
be regarding the second question in
terms of the the funding mechanism um if
the uh traditionally that is how it is
how um investigations are funded through
assessments on the assessed uh excuse me
on the regulated Utilities in this case
it would be um similar to any
investigations that we do where there's
a direct Nexus to the distribution grid
um which is why the electric utilities
would be assessed for
this follow up follow up so someone
doing battery storage is not
necessarily A is not necessarily utility
they're an independent could be an
independent entity how is that just
Justified that um thank you for the
question yes it would be justified in
the the fact that these would be
connecting to the distribution utility
would be just excuse me would be
connecting to the distribution system of
these utilities and then in theory um
potentially reducing costs provided that
they're cited correctly there's the
correct Market mechanisms um to cost for
those electric distribution to utilities
whether it's um reduction in future
upgrades needed or capacity or things
like that um but we' I'd be happy to
take back to legal council to have
another take a look at that and whether
there's a more appropriate funding
mechanism representative liwicki has a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um one of my
questions having been more you closely
related to the business is do these
batteries actually exist how many
kilowatt hours how many megawatt hours
of battery can be had be and how does
that compare with for instance uh the
marac station or you know some of our
existing generating facilities um thank
you very much for the question so for on
the the residential side uh Liberty
Utilities actually has a pilot project
where they have installed these in uh
residential um uh homes within their
service territory uh they are moving to
phase two of that invest uh excuse me
phase two of that pilot fortunately
phase two has then been wrapped in
wrapped up within their rate case um
which the department has filed
objections to um and was requested to be
dismissed um for a variety of reasons
completely unrelated to battery storage
but that is sort of where it sits in
from a regulatory standpoint within the
state um they are available on the on
the commercial Market I'm aware that
Tesla has power walls I'm sure there are
other companies that provide similar
services in which place um you
essentially have them as backup with in
residential homes uh regarding utility
scale the um US Department of energy has
provided funding um to a um one
particular facility in West Virginia um
it's a private firm um where they are
working on utility scale long duration
um battery storage um using iron rather
than lithium or other sort of um uh more
difficult to find um components um I am
not familiar and well versed in the C of
how it works um but my understanding is
essentially it's the rusting and
unresting of the of the iron um which is
how the the energy is
stored follow
up the question is do the batteries
exist how do they compare with existing
generating facilities thank you for the
clarification um yes they do exist
they're in their infancy um it would
depend on a variety of factors as to how
scalable those are so I can I'd be happy
to look up and do some additional
research and get you an answer as to
that thank you for that offer
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Elliott
uh so you said that the do that Doe D
currently does not have expertise in
batteries are there plans to add that
expertise given that we believe that
batteries are going to become more and
more important in terms of reliability
and especially um making sure that
renewal able energy is also going to uh
contribute to dispatchable energy thank
you for the question representative um
yes so by doing these investigations
right the department also gains that
knowledge and that expertise as part of
that process of where we can have folks
in house who learn more about these
through going through these processes
um I think that answers the
question representative muns has a
question thank you uh Mr chair thank you
for indulging me again um in in the bill
on page one lines 18 and
19 it it talks it it says reviews review
programs and regulatory requirements and
Juris other jurisdictions to identify
best practices for a potential
program and I'm not it's not clear what
that program
is um I I looked at the existing statute
and the existing statute talks about a
bring your own home bring your own
device program is that what you have in
mind here or what does that mean um
thank you for the question
representative that might have just been
a uh uh as we were putting together the
bill with Senator Lang that may have
been a key phrase that inadvertently got
dropped um I'm happy to go back and take
a look at the statute um that you cited
there and look um to make sure that um
if that was dropped um that we reinsert
it
followup followup if it is if it is that
which I suspect it probably is what is a
bring your own device program sure thank
you for the question uh bring your own
device uh essentially is where rather
than having a utility pay for your
battery storage within your home
essentially you have you pay out out of
pocket of yourself and go and and
install a battery device in your own
home thank
you okay any further questions for Mr
Elliot and the
doe seeing none I want to thank you for
being here we'll look forward to the
additional information you can supply to
help us decide what to do with this
legislation of course thank you I have
no more pink cards on this bill is there
anybody else who would like to say
anything about
it seeing none we're going to close the
public hearing on House Bill a Senate
Bill
540 and we're going to enter a lunch
recess we will resume our activity today
at 1 p.m. with a full work session on
the three bills that we heard last week
Senate Bill 303 Senate Bill 388 and
Senate Bill
1:00
e
okay good afternoon everybody and
welcome back to science technology and
energy
for Monday March 25th we are now going
to convene a full committee work session
on the three Senate bills that we heard
last week those are Senate bills
303-
FN relative to the use of renewable
energy funds by the department of energy
[Music]
388-397 relative to electric grid
interconnection for certain customer
generators we will not be discussing
Senate bills 451 and 540 which we just
heard in public hearings this
morning so we'll just confine our
deliberations this afternoon to 303 388
and
391 and we're going to start our
deliberations with a task that I
neglected to perform earlier and to
which I apologize to everybody for not
having done this I'm going to ask ask
representative PL to give us the blue
sheet information on the previous Senate
391 uh thank you
chair okay on the Senate Bill
303 the blue sheet was one in support
one oppose
online there was 14 in support zero post
388 the blue sheet was zero in support
zero
Post online 16 in support zero
post Senate Bill
391 the blue sheet was six in
support zero opposed
online 108 in support two oppos and
chair okay thank you by any chance do
you have blue sheet information on the
two bills we heard this
morning yes I do so Senate Bill
451 the blue sheet was one in support
one
opposed online there was five in support
opposed
540 blue sheet was 0
0 none in support none opposed online
three in support two Uno uh two
opposed okay thank you very much once
again I apologize for forgetting
to recognize representative PL so that
he could do the blue
sheet uh or inform about the contents of
the blue sheets that's an oversight on
my part I apologize okay so now let's
get started with a full committee work
session we'll start first with Senate
Bill 303
FN as amended by the Senate relative to
the use of renewable energy funds by the
energy to ref refresh everyone's memory
this is a little bit of a housekeeping
bill in that it
um
no that's the next bill I'm sorry this
is a a bill that um wants to allow the
department of
energy
to use some money from the renewable
energy fund for battery storage
projects and I'd be interested here your
reaction to this bill whether you think
it needs any changes any addition
subtractions what is the committee's um
battery storage was
removed that was removed it was an
amendment oh okay so either we put it
back in or we make it consist it largely
and largely fixes dates uh in the
current law and permits money for towns
and cities um permits rebates for some
older residential solar projects because
when the date was originally fixed but
if if they uh are doing some
redesigning focuses rebates largely for
the new projects and the battery storage
business was all
removed uh the goal is no alternative
compliance payments impacted by laws of
other
states um and
um that's that's essentially what he
said in this
testimony okay good thank you
representative Bernardi for refreshing
our memory about what this bill is
about so it also changes the date of the
issuance of the annual report by the
department yeah from October 1st to
November
1st beginning in 2024
okay all
right representative McGee I was just
going to say um I think the bolded
language in my understanding the first
section of the Bolder language on uh the
first page line starting at line 16
basically says
that um they may modify existing
programs or opportunities funding
allocations shall be subject to the
apportionment requirements under
paragraph X which is where they discuss
the apportionment of the funds that need
to be used um for low and middle income
projects as opposed to everything else
and then Part B under there that's also
bolded is the part that includes
subdivisions or municipalities that have
projects that are backed up in the
system waiting for um for funding in
order to go forward and in that section
says it is excluded from um from those
requirements the apportionment
requirements so those were the two
things that I thought the bill mainly
was trying to accomplish was to let us
use the money for those Municipal
projects that seem to be pending
that could really use some grants from
work yes I think you're
correct does anybody think uh this is
acceptable as is or do you think it
changed representative Thomas thank you
Mr chair um one of my questions on the
on this bill hearing was how what was
the plan to enfor inform towns and
communities about this program change
and I'm I'm not sure I had heard a good
answer to that but I'm not sure that it
would hold up this bill either but
mine I think that's a pretty common
right representative
Ms um one of
the things I was struggling with a
little little bit um in in um on line 14
where we talk about how um money to
individual projects is going to be
allocated um there's um a desire to
ensure that those are um directed to
individuals that meet the uh low to
moderate income standards which I think
is great um the new language relating to
political subdivision specifically says
that that doesn't apply which I I
understand um but I'm I'm wondering if
there couldn't be some language added
that
says that if it's a case of two
different communities competing for the
same amount of money if there's enough
money for everybody great but if there's
only a limited amount of money and
there's two different communities say
Portsmouth versus Berlin competing for a
limited amount of money does the low in
would the lowincome lower income
Community get the benefit of the doubt
first where would you suggest inserting
that um you can probably amend that
Clause B to to to instead of saying it
shall not be subject to the
apportionment re requirements add some
language kind of along the lines of what
I just said and the idea is is is that
uh it's only in a situation where
there's uh two different communities
competing for you know the available
money and I I can draft some language if
there's some interest in that so are you
talking about page one or page two page
okay all right any other suggestions for
potential
modifications before before we go any
further let me just say that what we're
doing here today is we're kind of just
brainstorming we're not going to go out
and write any amendments today what I'm
trying to do is is to
identify what might need to be amended
and how it might be done so that we can
put together a concrete proposal for
creating an amendment at some future
date so I like your idea representative
mons that we
consider prioritizing who gets the
money but um we don't have to write the
language right now but we should
identify where is the best place in the
bill to put
it representative liwi uh thank you Mr
chairman what I'm thinking I and I keep
thinking I don't know whether there's an
appropriate way to do it within the bill
but to look at cost benefit if we're for
instance you know it's we're looking at
spending money or giving money away and
um we don't know how much what the
return may be and for instance if we
spend a million dollars getting one
kilowatt hour of battery storage this is
not a good deal uh
so but and I as I say I don't know how
to put it into the bill or whether it
would even belong in this bill but I
keep thinking that about many of the
through okay representative
partiall thank you chair um I don't
think this uh Bill actually deals with
battery except for in the analysis and
the methodology it's the only place
where batteries are actually mentioned
and Joshua um I'm sorry Joshua Elliot
the doe suggested striking all the
language that's concerned about
batteries I I can appreciate your
concern about cost benefit analysis I
really do but I just don't think we need
to talk about batteries with this
particular Bill okay yeah and I was just
using that as a for instance um you know
it could apply to almost anything that
uh we're doing is that there should be
some relation between cost and
benefit and last let to follow up on
that because I I think we're in
agreement but uh is it possible if we
are going to amend this to this uh take
Joshua Elliot's advice and strike out
all references to batteries in the
bill they're not in the bill well
they're in the analysis and the
yeah I'm not sure how important the
analysis portion is but yeah we should
yes could you turn your mic on and
repeat that sorry about that yeah if we
just uh take under the analysis if we
take everything after this bill and put
a line through it up until the comma
then it would just say this bill deletes
the required renewable generation
incentives program and authorizes a
political subdivision incentive rebate
or grant program using the fund so that
would that would be clear yeah okay
that's that's a good change
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um I question the wording on lines 21
and 22 on page one where it says
political subdivisions I just haven't
seen that before should it be Municipal
Municipal no
okay it is correct that is a correct
thank you y for legislative language
maybe not for everyday language but
representative
Ms there was one other thing I was I was
a little bit concerned about with the
bill um and um on page two lines 21 and
22 repeals um several sections from
current statute and um those relate to
um solar programs I believe solar um
incentive programs and we heard some
testimony that um that
um that there was um those programs were
not working therefore we should
eliminate it but there was a commitment
to develop um you know a replacement
program and it concerns me a little bit
about eliminating something without
having a replacement available and I you
know wonder why we can't if the
program's not working why we can't
uh either leave it as it is until we
know what the language is or put the new
language
in Mr Elliot would you be willing to try
to see if you could shed some light on
that
question thank
you good afternoon Mr chairman uh again
Josh Elliott director of the division of
policy and programs with the Department
of energy um representative Ms thank you
for the question um regarding um the the
philosophy sort of behind it we wouldn't
want to if if kept in place until a
replacement is devised there's no
um we would be spending money that on a
program that we know to be ineffective
we wouldn't we can't zero out that
program we can't eliminate it without
clear
statutory um the repeals of these
statutes otherwise it directs us to
operate this program so we'd be spending
money on a program we know doesn't
work Mr
chair yes go ahead uh representative So
you you're you're saying that the
program is ineffective on what basis I
mean have we seen any reports on that
thank you for the question it's
ineffective in that sense that uh the
rebate offered amount is currently
$1,000 where there is the general belief
and thought uh that a a $11,000 rebate
is not going to make the difference
whether or not somebody installs a solar
panel in large part I'm sure there are
probably individual cases where that may
make a sense but um we end up seeing
that it just subsidized Solar
Development that otherwise would have
happened absent this um not truly
incentive new Solar
Development and these payments are from
the renewable energy fund itself that is
correct yes that is correct okay I'm
looking at the language of U RSA 362 F10
right at the
moment
did you have a hand up representative
Kaplan go ahead yeah thank you Mr chair
this is in reference to representative
leki's desire to have cost benefit
analysis built into this and I I
appreciate that that that that's a good
idea in practice but this is part of a
program the Rex program that already has
been determined to be of you know
benefit uh to the state uh so I'm not
sure how that would work and I'm not
given that those kind of analyses are
driven by all kinds of factors that take
many many years to work out and
adjudicated proceedings that whether or
not we could actually arrive at a a
workable definition of a cost benefit
analysis for these programs and given
that the program the larger program that
it's a part of has already been
determined to be of benefit to the state
uh it might be problematic that's just
thought
okay well we have
um well I see he's already left I was
going to say while we had Josh up the
table we could ask him more questions
but he was hiding behind oh
okay do you have any uh further
Josh representative McGee so to kind of
tie it up in a bow um so the way I look
at it is it safe to say that the effort
of this bill is to take the renewable
energy fund and focus it towards what we
know is an existing
need um so that we can address that
backlog as as um Mr Evans Brown has said
in his testimony of people that are have
projects kind of
pending thank you for the question um
it's it's sort of twofold in the one
sense that a lot of these programs have
been around for a while and of course
markets Chang they're different the math
works different projects pencil out that
may not have before or projects that did
no longer do for a variety of reasons um
unrelated to this um but which is what
we started our initial stakeholder
process of saying okay well what's
working what's not working you know I
can make certain assumptions but I
without talking to the folks out in the
field I don't know what's working what's
not working um so the goal of this is
really to refresh and reform the RF to
make sure that it's responding to the
needs of the market and the people of
the State of New Hampshire um in such a
way that is offering help to where they
need help rather than
um maybe where they needed help 10 years
ago yes followup so then the followup
would be in relation to representative
mun's question um if we were to take
Section B um on page one uh which starts
at line 19 to 24 if we were to um
basically say that for political
subdivision projects um that we would
they would not be subject to a pment
requirements under paragraph 10 but that
maybe there should be some kind of
deference given to is it do you see any
benefit or do you see it being a
hindrance for us to try and uh ask that
the monies be allocated to projects in
communities that uh are not all high
high income
communities thank you for the question
it is one that I think a lot of state
agencies are dealing with as as going
through the Biden uh the Biden admin
ministrations justice 40 initiative um
and it's a question really of of looking
at where we're putting our resources
right and it sort of gets to the Crux of
of the the underpinning of the RF of we
want to make sure we're incentivizing
projects that would not have otherwise
happened um I think it's it's a policy
decision I can say that our um we are
developing the process of developing a
um through an eecbg formula grant or
Energy Efficiency conservation block
grant a municipal solar program that is
designed to essentially be the guinea
pig if you will for something future
here and in the the scoring waiting um
within that program um does have it
tilted towards uh what would be
considered lower income communities the
the um the Crux is really how you define
lower income right what would you what
metric should we use as state agency so
if I'm implementing that and you were to
put in or the committee were to put in
language to that effect I think clear
definition of what you would consider
low income or what metric you wouldd
like to use because I could easily see
two different communities saying well
based on this metric I'm the lower
income no on this metric I'm the lower
income right so there would need to be
some sort of common definition of what
you would consider a lower income
Community which I think would be very
helpful and also if we used your
language of trying to incent programs
that wouldn't otherwise happen you would
have difficulty meeting that barrier as
well right yes yeah yes thank you so is
the language on page two starting at
line 10 that talks about 80% of the area
immediate income calculated by the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development is that the kind of metric
that would work in this
situation um I I think a metric that
could work we there's so there's a
variety of metrics out there depending
on what you're looking at what factors
you want to wait um one common one that
is used um is free and reduced lunch
enrollments because that's a pretty good
proxy of where a community might be um
say again oh I'm sorry um free and
reduced lunch enrollments um as a
proportion you could say okay if you're
over this number or below the state
average or you're above the state
average um that is just one there are
some issues with that data set just
because of the lingering effects of the
pandemic of where there weren't um uh it
was automatic versus having to actually
enroll the students in those programs
which caused a whole host of other
issues but um the so some of those
numbers I would have to check with our
colleagues at the New Hampshire
Department of Education to see where the
timing in that is um I'd be happy to get
back to the committee with a a good
metric that we thought would be the
right one to use um but I would I
wouldn't want to say something off the
cuff then find out later that from
somebody who knows more than I do about
the metric oh there's this tremendous
thing that there's this flaw underlying
that and you don't want to use that
because of and I I just don't know at
the moment off the top of my head yes I
think that would be useful if you could
make a couple of suggestions along those
lines representative Corman thank you
yeah I'm looking at uh page one line 20
and it says develop incentive or rebate
programs or competitive grant
opportunities so it seems to me there
are three different things here
incentive programs rebate programs and
competitive grant opportunities and when
we talk about uh deciding which uh which
Community would get a grant based on on
income I mean it seems like that would
be for the competitive grant
opportunities and for the incentive and
rebate programs those can actually be
tailored in various ways and could
actually be tailored so that they're
directed to lower income communities am
I correct in thinking that thank you for
the question um yes they could so that
language is actually a carbon copy of
what is above um on where you see right
actually on line 15 um so just to ensure
consistency throughout the statute we
use that language again um I think
contemplated by the department obviously
we would want to get some stakeholder
input on that but our thinking is that
our initial thinking would be that it
would be a competitive grant program
would the easiest way they can provide a
whole application of what they're doing
we can um target funds that way um as
you mentioned it's easier right if you
have competitive grant program you're
evaluating all of them at once versus if
it's a rebate program you're getting
them in as they come in you can't say
well I if I known this one was coming in
so
okay any other thoughts about this
bill sounds like we have a couple of
opportunities here to potentially make
it
better all right seeing no more hands up
I think we'll move on and go to Center
Bill 388 relative to administration of
energy
and in order to avoid the mistake I made
on the first bill I'll ask the clerk to
refresh our memory about what this bill
is
about
I think this one is more of a cleanup
Boe a bill requested by Doe and there
will be an amendment um it's a technical
cleanup Bill uh home owners being
households uh therefore renters can
qualify fix the report date section six
fixes exemption procedures for
assessment of expenses remove straggler
Wireless tasks um
Amendment uh to be supplied will address
new solar owner only ensure projects are
ready to move forward and adds by rule
or order in a couple of
clear as
mud no I remembered I was looking I'm
pretty sure Josh am I correct that you
sent us some suggested Amendment T
language for this I was trying to find
it uh yes thank you Mr chairman um I did
send a long suggested language um that
would accomplish the uh items that uh
the clerk had mentioned in his
recounting of this
bill was it a attached to your testimony
or yes so it is in it is in the
testimony letter um I also sent a a Word
document um to folks um so it's actually
if you're looking at the testimony
page yes I I found it and uh I know that
somewhere everyone everyone should have
a copy of this is that correct
yes everyone got one whether they still
true all right so I found
the the first suggested amendment is on
16 to
change the department of energy by rule
or order shall develop a process by
which Community solar developers can
apply for a for designation as Community
solar projects project as a community
solar project for new solar arrays
that's the new language that would be
added 15 and
Mr yes the department of energy
um do rules as well as
orders currently they do they do a lot
of Ru making
actually we gave them as you'll recall
when we created the department of energy
we gave them five years to move all of
the Pu rules that are now doe rules
because they thought it would take that
long to to do all that Ru
making how's that going by the way um I
we'll probably hear a lot more about it
in the next bill um but yes it's under
underway now um we're working through
water and sewer rules at the moment um
and then we had a public hearing um I
escape it escapes me as to which rule
set is going currently under uh is going
to have public comment either just did
or will in the near future um the rule
Set uh doesn't impact my division so I
couldn't tell you off the top of my head
what but it's on our website if you're
if folks are
curious excellent so the next suggested
amendment
is excuse me uh representative Corman
thank you um so because I'm relatively
new I actually don't know the difference
between Rule and Order can that be
explained to me please certainly Josh
sure I will I will give it a shot so the
I'm going to I'm going to do the ru one
because that's a little bit more
straightforward so under RSA 4 uh 5
541a um the each state agency in uh
state government is given rle making
Authority sometimes it's more explicit
in terms of the legislature saying You
must develop rules um I like to think of
it this way sort of legislation spells
out the framework and then rules fills
in all the little gaps in between so
it's literally everything from what form
is used to the font size to how
something is done you may say um
actually probably using the previous
example set up a a a program for low
income okay well what do we mean by low
income how should that look sort of
filling out all the details um that the
legislature doesn't need either should
say
um that the legislature may not
necessarily want to weigh into sort of
the everyday day-to-day operations of a
state agency um so those are the rule
sets that go through um that go through
the Jael carve process so our joint
legislative committee on um on
administrative rules um so it sort of
functions similar to the fiscal
committee where they meet on a monthly
basis and each state agency um presents
the rules to the Jael car committee um
they review them there's a whole process
about how they reviewed public hearings
things like that essentially to ensure
that as a state agency we're not making
up rules that fall outside what the
legislative directive
was so that is that is sort of rules in
a nutshell I'm sure if there are any uh
rules experts or those who folks have
served on jail car they may have a
better may take issue but that's sort of
a broad brush stroke um orders are a
more spe uh specific instance of where
the commissioner has actually given the
authority um to essentially
um um undertake a process c um that has
legal backing so if um for example um
this is usually where it comes into
contrast with rule so for example if you
have a rule set right you can say okay
we're making these decisions based on
this rule set absent a rule set there's
no sort of backing as to why you've made
a decision to do a versus b x versus y
um the order gives the ability to the
department to move forward and act on
those things and give it the legal
authority to do so um again within the
confines of where the the legislature
has said yes you can issue orders based
on this so essentially as you're going
through the process somebody who either
may not like it or wasn't chosen or
something like that can't say oh you
know what you didn't have the legal
authority to do any of that so therefore
I you can't choose anybody I didn't get
picked you have to you can't choose
anybody so that's sort of it in a
nutshell but it's only used in The
Limited circumstances where the
legislature has said yes by rule or by
order so order typically viewed as sort
of an interim before the formal rules
get adopted
thank
you so by adding this language by rule
or by order it allows the department to
rule and then enforce it with an
order or in some cases just to use an
order based on authorization given
somewhere else in statute to make to
make something happen so that's that's
that's the essential
the essence of of rule and
order so if we go back to lines 2123 of
the original
bill we can add to that sentence and
that demonstrates project Readiness that
seems like a reasonable addition any
that still on line page one lines 21 to
wait a minute yeah section three lines
21 to
23 there's a sentence that begins if
projects the suggestion is to
add after the word credit at the end of
that sentence a comma followed by and
that demonstrates project
period
and just to be a picky Garian since it's
about projects plural should be
comma so uh Mr could you
explain why you thought that's a would
be a good uh addition certainly um first
thank you representative Corman for the
grammatical correction I you know I read
through these a number of times and
there's still always stuff that I miss
so I always appreciate that um so yes
thank you for the question regarding uh
the addition of that demonstrates
project demonstrate project Readiness uh
this is this would only come into a
circumstance of where more than 6
megawatts of projects apply in theory
you could have a project that comes in
um under this program um and based on
the current statute is just of the
greatest onu credit so a project could
come in and say you know what we're
going to offer 99% of our output um for
our exports the monetary credits to go
to this um to go to this program for the
uh on build credits for the um LMI
customers that sounds great in principle
right although if you're reading through
an application you could see okay well
they don't have site control of where
they're proposing to build this or they
haven't done um you know there's no
interconnection point nearby that makes
sense for the size of the array that
they're talking that they're proposing
or for example Myriad of other sort of
issues like that that sort of tell the
reviewer I don't know if this project is
quite ready yet in the event that
there's more than six megawatts who
apply you could have some project that's
at the other lower end um you know I'm
going to make up a number say 30%
offering but they've already done you
know they've demonstrated site control
they have a clear financing plan they
have all these things that sort of show
yeah this project if is going to be is
will get off the ground this project
will happen you know assuming all all
else being equal versus sort of this
aspirational project um which doesn't
sort of pass the sniff test and then you
have a which would end up knocking out
that project that would actually get
done so if we were to just go purely
based on the largest on built credit
someone I don't know why they would do
this but someone in theory could file an
application with a very high number on
it just designed to occupy that queue
without actually having any intention of
doing the Project based on the way the
current statute is written our only
jurist our only um ability to weed out
those program or to to to make those
designations is based on the largest on
Bill credit so by adding and
demonstrates project Readiness we could
say okay this application for this
project they're clearly not ready yet
and by taking space in the queue they
are essentially ensuring that another
project that may have a lower on Bill
credit but is viable and actually is
ready to go would then not get included
so even though on paper oh well this is
a much better project because it's going
to offer all these other resources it's
not a real number versus the project
that gets kicked out even though it's
actually would have
happened okay I think that's a good good
addition representative muns thank you
thank you Mr Elliott so this so we so we
get in this bill we get it again at the
whole issue of low to moderate income
and the definition of those those
groups um so I'm curious as to what the
definition is we're using for this for
this bill and these programs but before
you answer that I I I have another
question I notic that we change the
language from low to moderate income
homeowners to low to moderate income
house households which in my
mind
[Music]
um uh kind of
in you know decrease looking throughout
the rest of that statute um the word
household is used um repeatedly
throughout that section of Statute
actually you can see it on line SE page
one line 17 for the product for the
benefit of households um the use of the
word household versus homeowner in this
sense um does not necessarily apply to
okay who income do you count versus
whose do you not count um it's to make
it clear that this program is available
for renters so even though you are not a
homeowner right you still have a
household so that would be the
distinction there now this the the
department has interpreted the statute
to be inclusive and by the references to
households that would mean including
renters so this is just a cleanup to
make sure the statute's consistent
throughout followup go ahead but what
would the what is the definition what's
the threshold and and then just getting
back to the uh the previous Bill
couldn't we use that same threshold sure
I am flipping back to the previous bill
um because there is the exact definition
of what LMI is uh in a tangential way
sorry
um yeah so there's part of it is up to
80% of Ami um which is essentially any
Resident of a um public housing
authority or section housing or
something like that um trying to recall
off the top of my head I can get back to
you on this I believe the threshold is
300% of federal poverty um but that is
done based on the household so for the
for 30 for the 303 Bill discussed
earlier um this program looks at the
individual households rather than the
community as a large as at a whole
excuse
me okay the other amendments suggested
by the Department have absolutely
nothing to do with this solar incentive
program they are changes to a different
part of RSA 362 F that apply to useful
thermal energy and they just add the
words by rule or order to two different
paragraphs now both of these useful
thermal energy
paragraphs
are paragraphs that were added by
Statute
last session or last
year that
split the definition of useful thermal
energy into two categories large and
small and exempt the small category from
uh certain metering requirements in
order to prove that it qualifies for rex
that was language that everybody
endorsed last year but by some for some
reason we left out the the language of
by rule or order which gives the the
department the ability to actually make
rules and enforce them so I think this
is a reasonable addition I'd be in favor
of it any comment or questions for Mr
Elliott representative Ms so that that
would be something new to the bill right
I mean there's nothing in the bill right
now that addresses that
correct this is a different section of
law the uh the thermal energy correct
yeah okay thank you it is Germaine
though because it addresses the same
statute if it addressed a different
statute it would not be Germain but IT
addresses RSA 362 F so it it is
Germaine representative Bernardi so I'm
in favor of going forward with all the
Amendments that Doe has proposed
here okay further comment representative
Thomas uh this is about the bill in
general not specifically this
conversation so is that's okay
absolutely okay um starting on line 25
on page two all of those rep repeals we
heard that they were repealed because
the personal wireless service is no
longer within the purview of the
department um does anybody own that now
or is that just
dead
yeah guess oh have any insight on that J
Josh sure thank you for the question
representative um so when those statutes
were originally drafted uh and passed
into law was I
believe 2010
2012 um where there wasn't a lot of um
sort of uh guidelines and parameters for
uh how local zoning should really take a
look at uh where the sighting of of
these essentially person wireless
devices essentially um cell phone towers
um since then it's been about 15 years
and there's pretty robust um uh
ordinances that have been adopted um
throughout the state for these
communities um so the really the the or
original charge was to sort of develop
these as part of um the office of energy
and planning as it was um back in that
that time frame to develop these model
orces to allow for local communities
essentially to start from rather than
starting from scratch they have a base
to start from and go from there so the
need for these um has um has sort of the
statutes have sort of outlived their
usefulness in which the the the need for
those things are no longer true
um okay okay so the repeal is just to
get rid of statutes that are no longer
useful that is correct my understanding
was it was sort of a one time of here
please go out and develop these model
ordinances these model things for the
communities to adopt um it was sort of a
one-time here please go do this it's
sort of uh irrelevant statute
now okay good representative Ms did you
have another question no
okay any
others representative
parshall yes uh thank you Mr Al for your
further testimony uh section four
received a little bit of scrutiny over
in the Senate can you uh paraphrase what
their concern was I see the amendment
did not change anything too much with
the original Bill thank you for the
question yes there was a um proposal the
original section 4 which is not in the
bill before you um actually sorry if I'm
flipping back to the as introduced
version um would have had uh the
department taking on some um rulemaking
regarding uh energy storage systems
including tariffs and there was uh
concern that um by stakeholders that
they thought this was a process better
left to the Public Utilities Commission
um which is why the department requested
phase okay representative
Thomas thank you um I'm just looking at
my notes uh from the hearing and on line
23 on page one I'd written down
demonstrated on Project Readiness is
that something that we had decided to
include yes okay we talked about that a
else all right I think we're done with
this
bill let's talk now
391 now we had an extensive public
hearing about this bill that lasted for
2 hours and 20
minutes oops
uh I'm sure all of us took a lot of
notes on this
bill
and I have
been uh made aware of a potential
amendment that clean energy New
Hampshire has sent around so I'd like to
ask Mr Evans Brown if he could come up
and let us know what the status of that
potential amendment is I actually have
some copies here which I could pan pass
out to the committee but I'm reluctant
to do so unless I know that it is uh an
amendment that might have some momentum
let's say yes uh thank you Mr chair uh
Sam Evans Brown executive director of
clean energy New Hampshire uh thank you
for the question um we were actually
just conferring prior to the hearing
getting underway and I think the
proposal is that we'd like to get the
parties to together to discuss how to
find a uh Common Ground um later this
week and so there are the department
does have con some concerns with the
amendment we have some concerns with the
bill as drafted um one thing I would
just like to flag and I was just looking
at the establishing statute for the
Department of energy um as I was sitting
in the the back there that I don't it it
feels there are certain roles for the
Department of energy and the Public
Utilities Commission that we have really
thought through as to what the duty of
each entity is in in my mind when you
read the statute establishing the
department it really is to administer
programs create policy um and and it's
not the regulator of the utilities but
it is true that in RSA 362
A9 uh comma x uh comma 10 through 12 the
department is tasked with creating
interconnection rules and I would argue
that that is perhaps not the right
entity to to engage in that very similar
to how that we felt the department was
not the correct entity to create uh
storage rules that that really is a an a
an act of regulation of the state's
Electric utilities as opposed to a
creation of policy or administration of
a program um so I would suggest we we
have suggested that we thought again
that the the the puc is the better
entity to to carry out the rulem um if
the department of energy wants to write
the draft rules that are considered as
the basis by which the the proceeding
gets underway that's something that we
think is perfectly reasonable um and
would' be happy to to have it proceed as
such uh there and I think much of the
debate really revolves around uh the the
creation of timelines and how that can
be done in such a way that it doesn't
fundamentally conflict with how JL car
operates um so that we wouldn't get
ourselves crosswise with the statutes
for for the joint legislative committee
on administrative
rules so thank you for that I still
didn't get an answer to the question is
this suitable for handing out to the
committee or not I would not um I think
I think you know if folks are curious to
see it certainly there's no secret uh
there uh but I Mr Elliot could come up
and speak to his concerns about the
amendment and I think we'd be better off
uh sitting down the the all the folks
that are concerned with this with this
bill later in the week and seeing if we
can find consensus language okay so uh
representative
bernardy so uh thank you Mr chair um Mr
Evans Brown the bill that we have in for
before us is to have the doe draft Draft
rules and then those go anomally to the
Pu for rulemaking proceedings so I don't
understand what you're trying to do here
that would be different than that or
improve prove the timing and why jel car
is involved at all if the rules never
become rules until the Pu does its
job certainly so so I think perhaps it
might be best to have Mr Elliot talk
about his concerns with how what we
drafted interacted with JL car um what I
would say is I think that the the
amendment that you all have before you
is actually quite unclear as to what it
requires in I I I see the language as as
not defin L requiring a rule making it's
it and I I apologize I don't have it
right in front of me but but my my
memory of the the wording is essentially
that they shall consider rules or you
know so so if if you'd like I can pull
it up and I can speak in a slightly more
informed way um but but the the our Our
concern is that the language does not
explicitly require Ru making and and
that is what we're attempting to to make
sure it's laid
out so he has a followup but I'm just
going to point out that I did pass out
that suggested Amendment language just
so people would know what we're talking
about just for transparency it's not
something we're going to consider but um
when you get the handout it's the
section
two Public Utilities Commission that's
the new section that um we're kind of
talking about right here so okay go
ahead and finish representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair so to me
it's very clear pu the doe is to do
Draft rules and it specifically says
draft rule shall do da da D all these
various things and then it goes the
draft fuels will be utilized by the puc
so the two hours of testimony that we
heard last week was we need rules now if
I can summarize and so the real issue is
what process expedites this process what
you know to make it
happen uh yes so so and and I am gon to
try to pull up the language here so that
so I can say exactly what our concern is
moment yeah so so uh the department of
energy shall open a proceeding to
examine and assess Draft rules and and I
think our concern is with that language
there specifically so a open a proced
proceeding to examine and assess what
does that mean does that mean they're
going to have a Ru making or they're
going to consider doing a rule making
and so uh in so far as as that's the
Department's intent is to is to have a
rul making then you know great let's go
um but but again I think uh we we do
have a fundamental policy concern here
which is what is the entity that
regulates the public utility the the
state's electric utilities and I I I
think you know it's it's one that's
worth
thinking through um that you know we
after the department of energy was
established the year that followed there
was a cleanup bill that did a lot of
sort of find and replace of commission
and department and I was actually just
looking at the statute and there's still
typos that are sort of littered
throughout the statute you know the and
and so so have we truly thought through
this particular aspect is I think the
question that we should be asking
ourselves so we basically have a lot of
work to do then on this bill right yeah
so let's uh let's let you off the hook
for the moment and or no you want to ask
a question okay representative mcke
wants to ask you a question yeah I just
wanted to clarify my understanding is
that um that the interconnection work
which started with
sp262 resulted in already a review of
the rules that are available I I mean I
think the report that we received in
December of last
year I would have thought would have
been where the draft of what we would be
considering would be considered because
it ended up there was a stakeholder
process and there was also uh a review
of existing connection models and so the
department of energy had done that work
and then the report kind of came back as
a sort of a uh it just
memorialized the information that it had
it had received and it regurgitated it
in that report but without any sort of
form or recommendation for what they
thought might be best out of that so
it's almost like we're undertaking the
same process again if we go back to ask
the doe to do a draft it I'm just asking
if if I'm looking at that correctly but
it seems like we spent quite a bit of
time doing an assessment and talking to
the stakeholders already yeah and I
would say that it was uh when Senate
Bill 262 was passed uh the the spike in
the quanti of interconnection requests
was just beginning and it hadn't really
reached the pitch that it reached I
think uh late last year and now
continues going forward and um so when
the investigation then kicked off our
strong recommendation from from you know
our organization as well as as many of
the stakeholders that we that we engage
with was that a Ru making should
commence and we were quite hopeful that
the study would recommend that as as an
as a policy outcome that should should
be engaged upon and and we were hopeful
that they would actually recommend this
piece of legislation um the fact that it
didn't do so is why Senate Bill 391 is
in front of you in the form that it is
is that the investigation did not
explicitly say what we need are rules
that do X Y and
Z follow up could that have
investigation could that investigation
have asked the Pu to go into Ru making
from there I'm we thought we thought we
were hopeful that would be case yeah
that would have been
good representative parshall you had a
question or I do one perhaps uh knowing
that uh Joshua OT may not be returning
ask this of you thank you for being here
um now do you think that I gather
there'll be some discussions outside of
this committee room uh and do you have
much confidence of the timeline with
specific dates and um Authority can be
established and we can hope for further
recommendations from the doe who
originally asked for this bill further
recommendations to further hone this uh
un Amendment would further make these
concerns of yours clear which are my
concerns as well can we expect that uh I
I am very confident that we can we can
get to yes on this bill I don't see any
reason I I think the concerns about the
timeline and and whether or not the way
that they're crafted in the amendment
that we put forward is you know in
conflict with how rule makings uh
proceed are are totally uh something
that we can we can figure out uh it's
just a question of of where how do we
lay out essentially a procedural
schedule between now and and when rules
are are uh set to be approved by the Pu
and put in front of jail car and and it
really just takes someone who who you
know can walk that calendar back and
then say okay here's what we're going to
lay out in um in what what needs to be
laid out in statute and what doesn't
what can we simply come to agreement
that here's how we're going to do it
well thank you for your efforts on this
area and I have no further questions
thank you representative mutts thank you
Mr
chair at the risk of opening the
Pandora's Box that I think we were
trying to avoid um would it be
appropriate to ask the doe what their
concerns with the language in this
proposed legislation is if you're asking
please should I step away yeah I I I
I'll leave leave that to the chair
discretion Mr ellot do do you feel
comfortable addressing that now or would
or okay are there any other questions
for Mr Evans
Brown okay seeing none thank you Sam and
now Mr Elliot will come back up and
maybe give us a a preview
of when I when I said the legislation I
meant the amendment yes in preview of
what uh um May transpire with the
amendment uh good afternoon again Josh
Elliot director of the division of
policy and programs for the doe um I
want to preface my comments with saying
that uh the department wants to get to
yes department wants to get to yes on
this bill um walking back sort of
through the process of how we got here
uh Senate Bill 262 had us go through the
the the process getting stakeholder
input um and there wasn't there were
some areas of agreement but there were
some major areas of disagreement um and
that is sort of the underpinning piece
of this Ru making process right it's
this sort of Byzantine process that
unless you're member of Jael car or your
state agency actually involved in this
is sort of this opaque okay how exactly
do all does all this work um taking a
step back of the question of who should
be doing this R making um if you look at
the 900 rules itself and as I as we had
the conversation earlier the rules are
are directed by Statute and they have to
tie to statute and the rules are done
based on those statutory right they're
not they don't come out of thin air they
come out of come out of what the statute
authority authority is if you look at
the current 900 rules they're all tied
to RSA 362a which is the net metering
statute which is what the department has
oversight of as part of the organization
of the department if there's a policy
decision that the department should not
have oversight over net metering and
that less what the Tariff should be
which is part of the pe's public
utilities commission's
process then that statute then that
needs to change right every single
reference to Department in RSA 362a
needs to be swapped back to the
commission because that is the only that
would be the only thing that would make
sense for the rul making just as for
example the department of energy would
not be responsible for the rule making
for department environmental services it
does not make sense to have the Public
Utilities
Commission overseeing and implementing
the rule process for a different state
agency there can be questions debate
about whether or not the department
should have the oversight over that
statute but that is the statute as it
currently exists um having conversations
with the Pu um they have no interest or
the bandwidth to take this on um if they
were given funding and additional staff
maybe that answer would change but um as
part of my direction in the bill is
introduced um the Public Utilities
Commission asked me um to convey to the
committee that they did not have the
bandwith nor the interest of underdoing
this process um which is in my Senate
testimony on the bill so that being said
makes sense that the department has that
rulemaking Authority right we have the
jurisdiction over the statutes therefore
we develop and implement the
rules typically most rules are not
controversial right the the decisions
have already been made there are no
points of contention in this one
depending on who you talk to but based
on the fact that the are the uh Senate
Bill 262 process did not come out with a
recommendation at the end saying yep
here it is here's the model you want to
go on we have a couple of changes
everyone's all in agreement right that's
not what the outcome was which is why
the department proposed doing working
groups on these particular issues um in
particular uh on on these questions of
interconnection and sort of these okay
well which models you use again I've
I've made reference to there were six
different proposals that were done uh
that were put forward for consideration
as part of that
process that being said when you get to
the rul making process the idea is that
you are presenting a clean set of rules
to jel car and that they examine them
based on okay does this actually tie to
statute the statutory authorities there
and there's a variety of things that
they look through as they're going
through and vetting rules and there's a
public hearing process there's a whole
there's a whole process that goes along
with it for stakeholder input and and
other
considerations including legal review
and that the the Jael cart staff issue a
recommendation there's various steps
that it can go through either approved
or or require just kick back to the
agency the idea is that you have a clean
set of rules that everyone's in
agreement on the concern of the
department is that there's not agreement
on all these things right you could put
in a a timeline and we would be required
by Statute to go to Jael car and say
here you go here's the set of rules uh
not everybody agrees on this there are
different parties and you know we had a
deadline set by the legislature so here
you go um that then that process could
then just go through could go through
the jail car process but there's sort of
this assumption that the doe in this
process has the final say and can force
compromise we can't we can come up with
the Draft rules we don't have that
hammer we don't have that okay knock
everyone's heads together and get
compromise on this we don't have the
authority because it is Jael car at the
end of the day that has that Authority
so we could do our process we could do
everything we could be collaborative we
could get all the stakeholders together
we could go through this whole process
but a deadline doesn't do anything a
deadline would say Okay submit the rules
if there's agreement then okay then
we're all set if there's not agreement
then the whole thing just moves over to
Jael car and then the fight the fight
out of the draft rule process moves from
not from the Department's process then
moves to the jail car process and then
you know if somebody didn't like for
example okay there was a disagreement on
I'm going to take a issue with days
right okay we one group says okay we
should really have it 60 days the other
group says no it really should be 30
days in the department maybe a salic
answer says okay we're going to pick 60
days WR smack dab in the middle either
of the parties who didn't like that
answer could then just go to J car and
start lobbying the members of jail car
and saying vote down these rules the
reason I say this is because I don't
want this process set up to fail I don't
want us to be in a situation of where we
go through the process we deliver them
to jail car and then the whole process
gets blown up because then it just gets
kicked right back to the apartment and
we start right back over again I do not
want to commit staff time energy and
resources to a process where I think has
a good chance of failing because I don't
think that serves anybody including
folks Mr Evans Brown uh Mr um ban Etc
who are working on this bill is we want
to get to yes our concern is we want to
make sure it's implementable we don't
want to go down a road and spend all
those time and effort and resources just
to be right back where we are today
doing the same thing I understand in
most other circumstances right deadlines
make sense right it compels somebody for
example here the legislature you have
deadlines to get out FN bills and bills
going to Second committees right at some
point it forces that decision to be made
in this situation the department is not
the final Arbiter and that's why the
deadline doesn't make sense
I get it from a conceptual standpoint
and I understand I heard the the
testimony all of you heard um on this
question um right there's a need and
there's a there's a desire and there's
certainly issues here that need to be
addressed the department doesn't dispute
that or argue with that we want to make
sure that the process actually gets us
to where we need to
go sorry monologue the Department's
investig investigatory proceeding then
did recommend the set up setting up of
some uh working groups to resolve these
issues is that correct yes so as the
report that was issued recommended the
setting up setting up of two different
working groups to work on two separate
issues the sort of getting into the
Weeds on these these rules was one of
those working
groups and has anybody made an attempt
to set up these working groups yet this
bill was then introduced which sort of
circumvented that process so the
department made the decision okay if the
legislature is going to step in here why
should the agency spend the time and the
effort on doing these things when then
this bill is pending before you so the
department wants the legislature to be
the working group basically no not
necessarily we were committed to work
having those working groups set up and
then this sort of undercut those working
groups so then as a rational decision
say okay well if the legislature is
going to do this or take action on this
why should we spend all the time and
effort over here if the legislature is
going to direct us to do something
anyway so maybe I should have said this
is kind of falling in the legislature's
lap at this point all right
I think I understand what the issue is
here representative muns you have a
question um so if you know if if if the
legislature wants to try
to make sure that this these rules get
um uh programed you know as quickly as
possible um and you feel you don't have
the authority to be the final Arbiter is
there something that you would you would
want us to do to give you that
Authority so this is what I believe sort
of the the underpinnings of the Jael car
process is to make sure that there is
agreement on all these things so Jael
car that the rules have the full force
and effect of
Statute having controversial rules this
sort of system is designed in order to
make sure that those don't happen by
having this open and transparent
process so in order to sort of Force
everybody would require either clear
legislative direction to say here
spelling out every single Last Detail of
those rules of what they should include
and what those timelines are which I
don't think this committee or any
Committee of your colleagues and other
committees would want to be able to do
um but I understand it's right it it is
sort of one of those messy facets of
democracy right to to be able to make
sure you want to have all of that
input but at this but it takes time
right it takes
time
followup yes go ahead yeah no I I I
think you know a transparent process is
the ideal process and you want and I
agree with you you want to try to bring
people together and get consensus but um
at some point the process has to end and
and you know and how do how do we make
how do we do you do you feel like you
have the authority
to to end that process at some point
and or do you do we want you to have
that Authority I guess is the the bigger
question right at some point the process
would end right we would get through
everything and it may be us and one of
the parties or one of the groups um
saying yes this is what we think and
there may be one of the other parties
that says no that is absolutely terrible
then that goes to we could still submit
those rules but we would want to make
sure okay if we tried every single last
effort can we get compromise here right
at the end of the day and I know folks
want to have this happen quickly in an
expedition ious way the department is
ready willing and able to do that it's a
matter of all the parties coming
together and agreeing on all of those
facets so I know the parties want to
move quickly they're going to have to
all come together to to sort of say okay
where are your red lines where can you
negotiate where are you okay with and I
think part of my um testimony earlier on
the bill was not um you know not what do
you approve but what can you live with
what are you okay with you may not like
it but what are you okay with and I
think um
as part of the rule process it it's I
wish I had some sort of way to cut this
gordian KN right of saying okay this all
everybody's got to come together
everyone has to answer these questions
and everyone's got to basically pick and
then commit that no one is going to then
go to jail car and Lobby members of jail
car if they don't like their way way
decided well one thing we have working
in our favor here is today is March
25th and I just looked in the house
calendar and the last day to act on
Senate bills is May
16th so we
have 45 50
days to try to come to some kind of a
resolution obviously to get it out of
this committee to the house floor by the
16th we would have to be done by about a
week before the 16th but um so the first
week of May but still that gives us 45
days so it sounds to me like what we
need to do and we have done this many
times before since I've been in the
legislature I did it with Senator
Bradley on House Bill 1116 way back in
2015 I did it on House Bill 315 in 2020
I did it with um House Bill
549 convened working
groups
and hammered out the issues and got to
an agreement and then that's what we put
into legislation so it sounds to me like
that's what we have to do again we have
to convene a working group I know clean
energy no Hampshire and ever Source
wants to be part of that working group
um and they will suggest any other
stakehold holders that need to be part
of that working group pachy Campbell I'm
sure would like to be part of that part
of that working group so we'll come up
with a a working group and
many of the working groups that I've
dealt with in the past have
been uh Zoom meetings we've conduct
conducted them via
Zoom um the the working group we did
with Senator Bradley on houseu
1116 was a in was in person and we could
do that again as well so I I think we
can put together something that can try
to resolve the issues so that then we
could create legislation that will
Implement what we want to to see done I
will just add I think U Mr Evans Brown
made this comment um myself Mr Evans
Brown Mr Monahan and Mr lato are all
meeting at uh on Thursday to discuss so
excellent I'll be interested to hear
what you what you come up with and if we
need to can go further and and a convene
a working group that adds other people
we can do that if you can work out all
the issues yourselves and get back to us
that would be great too but I'm I'm
willing to do a working group if we have
to representative Corman thank you so I
I understand what you're saying about
gel car being I guess the last stop in
the
process now these rules are going to be
rather technical aren't
they yes excuse me thank you for the
question yes most of them are um in
terms of uh if you look at the existing
rules for smaller arrays yes most of
them do get fairly technical yeah so I'm
just wondering is is gel car even
capable of evaluating such technical
rules um they are um they've done
similar in the past um for um both our
agency um and for Myriad of other
agencies um that do very technical
things cing Dees do Etc okay and the
speaker initiated a new process this
year he uh has created a
uh rules of review subcommittee within
each house committee so here in science
technology and energy
myself Vice chair Thomas representative
McGee and you representative Corman are
the four members of the subcommittee
that evaluates Jael car rules for
science technology and energy now you
may be wondering we haven't done that
well that's because so far there haven't
been any rules proposed that I thought
needed our review but we are a
subcommittee that will review Jael car
rules uh if we feel that it's necessary
to do so to make sure that they conform
with statute thank you for telling me
I'm on the
subcommittee I thought I I thought that
had already been conveyed to you
no uh representative
bernardy in addition to that jel car
also sends out a notice of rules of
every uh committee Commission agency
that they're reviewing on a periodic
basis and said you can look through them
this is to all the legislators you look
through them you can identify if there's
something you want to zero in on to see
if it complies with the statutes that
you are interested in and send your
comments to jel car so we are all on the
hook is is that the ru making register
emails I get yes it is yes and
that's representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman so I I have a question that
goes back to uh I wrote down doe has
Authority under 362a which is a net
metering statute so you're looking for
statutory Authority in order to make
sure that when you present what you're
presenting to Jael car for consideration
that there's a statutory link so the
question is if interconnections don't
always have to do with n metering so is
that the right place or uh I mean I I
think you can link it there but but
interconnections are not always net
meters right so is it is that the right
place for it to be or do we have to
rethink that too so thank you for the
question so all of the statutory
references that the the pc900 rules
which are the interconnection rules or
the net metering rules excuse me um are
all linked back to the to that statute
um that's where the statute statutory
Authority lies in order for us to
develop those those variety of things
dealing with net metering including
inter interconnection is one of those um
it would require statutory changes to
move it to a different agency or if it
wanted to be the Pu it would require
them taking over all of those statute as
well so you do the statute paired with
the rule not not separate so 900 is the
rule I'm just trying to understand oh
I'm sorry yes so P so the current yes so
I'm sorry um the current um p900 rules
are where all of the net metering um
rule sets are and there's a variety of
different things including everything to
down to you know how you do meters what
meters qualify and things like that um
that all of that statutory def all of
those statutory um Authority all ties
back to the net metering statutes which
is
362a so you so in followup yes go ahead
so you would Envision interconnection
which is already listed
there uh under the 900 rules section you
would Envision it
being these findings would be um
listed there as well that that that's
where they would be tied back yes so
there is current in in in roles right
now so we have set up for
interconnection for less than 100
kilowatts all all so it's already I'm
sorry it's already in the 900 rules I
can't remember exactly which one I'm
sure someone will correct me um within
the 900 rules there is a reference to
larger interconnection project which is
the one we're talking about here which
says shall defer to the Tariff of each
of the utilities so right there is
technically a rule for larger
interconnection just says go over here
for this instead we're not putting it in
it's not in in rule so this would
clearly give us the direction okay to
take rather than just saying defer to
the Tariff actually spell out everything
like we've done for small customer
generators okay thank you I don't know
if you know the answer to this Josh
but one of the things I wondered about
with this Senate Bill 391 is it appears
to be drafted as session law rather than
and that seems to that would seem to be
a problem or not what do you what is
your judgment um I can't speak to the
question as to why it was session law
versus put into the statute itself um I
don't know if that was a choice of the
Prime sponsor or a suggestion by um alls
I can't I can't speak to that um I don't
think it presents an issue one way or
the other you could either put it in
statute or put it in session law I think
it would be um I don't see a material
difference between doing it one way or
the
other oh okay all
right any further um questions or
discussion with
Josh it's 2:30 so oh did somebody raise
their hand all right I I just
representative Ms I don't have a
question for Mr Elliott but I just had a
before we split I was just kind of
curious what okay Josh you're you're
you're excused it
were I I just was curious kind of where
we where we landed in terms of next
steps I mean I know there was talking
about convening subgroups Etc I was just
going to address that issue so I think
what we'll do is we'll wait until we
hear from how the meeting on Thursday
goes
and if I hear from a couple of the
participants in Thursday's meeting that
a working group is necessary we will
form one
and our working group will be comprised
of stakeholders and any legislators who
are interested in participating any
members of the committee who are
interested in
participating I've worked with working
groups in the past that had as many as
15 18 people so um it takes a little
longer to get through a working group
with that many people but you you do get
something accomplished eventually if you
stick with it uh HB
315 was a great example of that that was
the the bill from 2020 that
um corrected issues with RSA 53e the
community power Community aggregation
legislation which was deadlocked in a
rules
impass and uh HB 315 resolved with a
work working group all the issues so
that uh we could put forth legislation
that allowed the ru making to move
forward and to everybody's satisfaction
so that would be the model we would use
for a a working group if we had to have
one for this bill so that will be our
next step would be to create that and U
so I will let you know at the end of
this week or early next week whether we
need to form a working group or
not and that can bring us to the end of
our activity for
today now next week is a huge question
mark right at the
moment we only have at the moment the
five bills that we've already heard from
the
Senate we don't have any additional
bills coming our way that I know about
there is a rumor that there are some
more coming our way but I don't know
what whether that will actually happen
or
not and we have as as I said earlier
until May 16th or maybe the work week
before to finish our work on these
Senate bills so we have plenty of time
so as a result I'm thinking that we may
not do anything next week we may take
the week off and uh not return to
committee work until the following week
which would be April the week of April
the 8th we won't do anything on the 8th
because that's Eclipse day but we may
meet on April
9th um but that's TBD so just keep your
eye on your email inbox and I'll let you
know if we have to form a working group
on Senate Bill
391 we may do that prior to the 9th and
I will try to decide based on what kind
of Interest I get
for participation by members of the
committee I'll try to decide whether it
has to be a noticed meeting or not if
there are enough members of the
committee
participating that we U we have a quorum
of the committee then it'll have to be a
noticed
meeting so we'll decide that uh as we
get closer to it so with that does
anybody else have anything they'd like
to discuss with the full committee here
this afternoon
okay seeing none we're done thank you
everybody whoops representative Bernardi
with a late hand
here late discovered
hand
um we received uh comments uh back from
uh ISO New England on uh a good visit
that we had there and they requested
that if we had any further questions
that were not able to be answered in the
time frame that we were there please
submit them so if any body does have
additional questions please send them to
me and I will collect them and forward
them to ISO New England for further
communication and
response okay anything else we are done
everybody